Ich bin so vorbeikommen, wie ich kann, Mr. Anderson. Wir wissen, dass du von einem bestimmten Individual getroffen bist. Aber ich denke, ich habe eine bessere.
Hier hört CRE Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Hier ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 192. Ausgabe in dieser Sendereihe, wo immer viel gesprochen wird. Und diese Sendung ist insofern was Besonderes als nicht nur, weil sie jetzt nach einer längeren Pause des Programms hier für etwas Fortsetzung sorgt. Nein, sie ist auch in gewisser Hinsicht eine Fortsetzung noch von etwas viel älteren Datums tatsächlich. Nämlich wollen wir zurückblicken und dann auch anschließen an eine Sendung, die tatsächlich vier, dreieinhalb Jahre zurückliegt und mit einer Einschränkung daher kam, die hier nicht üblich ist. Sie wurde nämlich live gesendet, damals in so einem kleinen UKW-Radio-Projekt und war von daher zeitlich beschränkt. Und es hat sich dann irgendwie gezeigt, oder zumindest war dieses Gefühl da, dass das irgendwie nicht ausreichend war. Konkret ging es um CRE 91, also schon über 100 Sendungen her. Und mein Gast war Gregor Sedlag. Oder ist es auch heute wieder?
Hallo Tim.
Hallo Gregor. Und jetzt sitzen wir hier. Und wir haben uns, ich weiß nicht, wann haben wir uns das vorgenommen, das mal zu tun? Bald danach.
Eigentlich schon in der Sendung?
Ja, das ist ja natürlich schnell so dahergesagt, ne?
Ja, ich glaube, du warst auch in der Sendung selber total verwirrt über den gesamten Verlauf des Gesprächs. Und ich hatte so den Eindruck, so ein leichtes Kopfschütteln bei dir über die ganze Situation zu sehen. Und mein Eindruck ist, dass du eigentlich erst überzeugt warst, dass es eine gute Sendung war, als relativ viele positive Kommentare zu der Sendung reingekommen sind, die vielleicht dir auch das Gefühl gegeben haben, dass ich nicht totalen Quatsch erzählt habe.
Na ja, da hatte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz so viele Sorgen. Ich war nur in vielerlei Hinsicht etwas überfordert. Das war die erste, glaube ich, dieser Sendung, die wir dort gemacht haben. Das heißt, es war dann auch das erste Mal. Da folgten dann noch drei. Wir sind irgendwie zehn Minuten vorher da reingerasselt und wie das eben so ist beim Live-Radio. Man muss dann halt in dem Moment übernehmen und wo wir vielleicht sonst ggf. da noch eine halbe Stunde vorher gesessen hätten und das eine oder andere durch den Kopf gerollt haben, worüber man jetzt mal konkret redet bzw. wohin die Reise gehen könnte.
Das war auch so ein Ladenlokal und dauernd sind auch so Leute an uns vorbeigelaufen.
Ja, es war verwirrend. Aber insofern war es wirklich ein Stunt und eine Herausforderung. Und naja, wir wollten dann mal einen Anschluss machen.
Ja, und ich muss dazu sagen, ich wäre gar nicht angetreten, wenn nicht das Missverständnis geherrscht hätte, wir hätten drei Stunden. Vielleicht, ich habe es einfach wirklich so, dass wir mindestens drei Stunden Zeit hätten. Und deswegen habe ich auch diese weitausholende Beginn gemacht. Ach so, jetzt müssen wir noch mal mit dem Disclaimer, so eine strenge Empfehlung an alle Hörer.
Das ist jetzt ernst gemeint. Wir schließen an diese Sendung an, weil wir sie irgendwie so für so ein bisschen, also wir haben sie für unvolländerter gehalten, als wir es jetzt glaube ich gerade selbst tun.
Wir haben sie eben gerade gehört.
Genau, das war nämlich die Vorgabe. Wir haben gesagt, wenn wir einen Anschluss machen, dann hören wir uns die Sendung vorher gemeinsam beide an. Genau das ist jetzt gerade erfolgt. Kurze Pause, noch mal ein bisschen kaltes Wasser ins Gesicht und jetzt sitzen wir hier.
Und wir stehen wirklich noch unter dem Eindruck, das Podcast.
Genau, und wenn ihr jetzt wirklich eine realistische Chance haben wollt, dem Inhalt zu folgen, dann müsstet ihr jetzt eigentlich auf Pause drücken und CRE 091 Poststrukturalismus euch noch mal geben. Das ist ein hartes Programm. Es gibt ja Podcasts, da möchte man manchmal ein bisschen schneller schalten. Ich würde hier eher dafür plenntieren, dass man diese auf 90 oder 80 Prozent der Geschwindigkeit hört oder zumindest einfach sehr aufmerksam dem Ganzen folgt. Das haben wir jetzt auch versucht zu tun. Trotzdem müssen wir jetzt, glaube ich, mit so einer kurzen Zusammenfassung anfangen. Worüber haben wir eigentlich gesprochen?
Also mein Verständnis aus dem live Erleben und jetzt eben ja noch mal das erste Mal wiedergehört.
Dem zeitsoberinnen Nachhören.
Ja, aber aus dem direkten Erleben ohne Nachhören hatte ich immer das Gefühl, das ist so eine Mount Everest-Besteigung und wir haben es also gerade mal aufs Vorgebirge geschafft und gucken auf den noch wolkenverhangenen Gipfel. Und dann war die Sendung zu Ende. Ganz so schlimm fand ich es jetzt nicht. Ich würde fast sagen, wir haben ein Basislager erreicht an der Stelle, wo man dann eigentlich anfangen muss, sich die Sauerstoffflaschen reinzubehalten.
Das haben wir natürlich jetzt auch gemacht. Wir sitzen also hier in voller Montur.
Und ja, es ist doch eigentlich gelungen, das Schwierige war ja quasi dieser Wrap-up, der zweieinhalbtausend Jahre Philosophie- Geschichte mal kurz zusammenzupacken, um dann hinterher den Poststrukturalismus überhaupt von seiner ganzen Fragestellung vernünftig darlegen zu können. Plus noch, dass ich dir das ganze Thema ja nicht als Philosophie-Thema versucht hatte zu verkaufen, sondern dass ich gesagt habe, ja, dieser Poststrukturalismus ist die Theorie, die man anwenden kann, um sehr viele Phänomene, gerade jetzt der Netzkultur, der Hacker-Kultur und auch generell des politischen Systems und der politischen Allgemeinzustands der Welt, dass man das da ganz gut darauf anwenden kann und dass einem ein anderes Bild der Welt vermittelt, das vielleicht etwas ja dem der Zersplitterung der Welt, wie man sie vielleicht empfindet, angemessener ist. Das ist die passende Theorie zur Zeit. Und da sind wir gar nicht hingekommen und das wäre also auch ein Punkt, wo man jetzt sagen könnte, dass wir jetzt nicht noch mal wieder in diese extrem theorielastigen Herleitungen einsteigen müssen.
Aber ich will es trotzdem mal zusammenfassen, ohne es jetzt zu plump zu machen, aber auch ohne zu philosophisch zu werden. Also zwei Dinge haben wir so betrachtet. Im Wesentlichen war es ja so ein historischer Rückblick, ja, was ist so passiert mit der Menschheit so und abgesehen davon, dass irgendwann mal zu Bauern wurden und Weizen angepflanzt haben, hat sich halt irgendwann eine technologische Beschleunigung in der Gesellschaft ergeben, wo dann überhaupt dieser Begriff Fortschritt eine bestimmte Bedeutung erlangt hat. Die Moderne, die erfüllt war von Zukunftsträumen und die sicherlich auch ihre Kulminationspunkte gefunden hat in so etwas wie der Mondlandung etc. Ja, so dieser ewige Traum, dass man, ja, dass es auch immer schneller geht und dass eben, wie du dann im Gespräch auch gesagt hast, dass einfach so auf einmal die Veränderung in der Gesellschaft so ein bisschen die wesentliche Konstante wurde, wo vorher die Dinge dann doch im Wesentlichen sich immer im selben, zumindest im selben technischen Kontext abgespielt haben und von daher eben sich die Welt nicht so am laufenden Meter geändert hat. Irgendwann nahm alles eine enorme Beschleunigung auf, vor allem getrieben durch die Technologie. Mein Beispiel war dann erstmal Strom, man könnte irgendwie die Telekommunikation, alles mögliche, natürlich dann auch diese gesamten revolutionären Entdeckungen der Physik, der Chemie, der Medizin im 20. Jahrhundert, also kennen wir alles. Und dann hast du aber auch einen zweiten Punkt markiert, das war jetzt eine sehr persönliche Sichtweise und man kann über den genauen Zeitpunkt streiten, aber so irgendwann Anfang der 80er Jahre, wo die Moderne so in die Postmoderne übergeht und sich das Verhältnis der Menschen zu diesem Dauerfortschritt und diesen permanenten Verwandlungen irgendwie ändert. Mit diesen Bewegungen einher geht eben auch eine philosophische Begleitung und die Philosophie, die irgendwie die Moderne gepaart hat, so mit der Aufklärung, die Erweckung des Menschen, ein anderer Blick auf die Welt, die Trennung von von von Gottheiten und eben dann auch der Versuch, sich seiner selbst gewahrt zu werden und zu sagen, ja hier, ich bin ein vernünftiger Mensch und weil ich das tue, so wie Descartes gesagt hat, deswegen gibt es mich auch schon und es muss jetzt nichts von außen kommen, was irgendwie das macht. Und jetzt habe ich den letzten Schlussfolger nicht mehr so ganz.
Ja gut, da geht es wie den Sozialdemokraten. Die sprechen ja auch immer noch ganz, die Grünen übrigens auch, vom Projekt der Moderne. Und genauso erschöpft wie die sozialdemokratische Bewegung ist bisschen auch dieses Denken, weil es eigentlich nicht mehr alles fasst, was passiert. Und da war immer noch diese, die haben immer noch eine strikte, positivistische, fortschrittliche Idee, dass man die Dinge besser machen kann von Generation zu Generation. Und das ist ja auch eine Art Glaubenssystem. Also Fortschritts-Dogma, Fortschritts-Glaube ist so ein Punkt, wo das poststrukturalistische Denken einfach sagt, passt auf, da seid ihr einer eigenen Ideologie aufgesessen. Und das ist natürlich dann auch wiederum das, was die Aufklärung verlangt, wenn man die Emanzipation von den selbstgemachten, vom Menschen erzeugten Widerständen und Zwängen und wenn man quasi dieser Fortschrittsglaube ist, ein weiterer Zwang, dem sich die Menschheit seit andere Zwänge hinter sich gelassen. Religion, Glaube, Hierarchie. Aber viele und die Moderne schlechthin ist gewissermaßen in diesem Fortschrittsdogma gefangen. Und das ist ein Zwang in sich. Und wenn die Aufklärung gewissermaßen so das Prinzip der Moderne ist, dann ist eben, muss auch so ein Zwang hinterfragt werden.
Und der Poststrukturalismus, an dem wir dann geändert sind, ist sozusagen das Prinzip der Postmoderne?
Ja, das sind diese zwei Möglichkeiten, in der ich habe in dem zum Ende des Podcasts quasi eher diese negative Sicht des Werterelativismus genannt. Das ist die eine Interpretation. Man kann aber auch sagen, es ist gewissermaßen Form von Hyper-Aufklärung.
Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist so der Kern des Poststrukturalismus setzt sich ja philosophisch mit der Frage eigentlich der Kraft von Aussagen auseinander.
Ja.
So, man schaut so auf die Welt, wie kommunizieren alle irgendwie miteinander, was sind so die Bedeutungshoheiten und wo man vorher gerne so mit der Aufklärung so eine allgemeine Erkenntnis postuliert hat, der sich dann alle anschließen und jetzt haben wir uns endlich auf irgendwas geeinigt und so funktioniert die Welt und da gibt es jetzt kein Gott, sondern wir sind jetzt halt einfach mal so wie wir sind und wir einigen uns auch auf Sprachen und auf Symboliken und auf Begriffe und damit auf gemeinsame Werte und das ist so die Basis, mit dem wir so voranschreiten.
Und das ist ja auch kultifiziert, es gibt ja sowas wie die Menschenrechts-Karta. Da kann man ja, das ist ja quasi das Programm der Moderne, auch kultifiziert und unterschrieben von allen relevanten Autoritäten auf dem Globus.
Also den Staaten?
Den Staaten, der Staatengemeinschaft. Und das ist natürlich erstmal schon eine tolle Sache, dass es nicht durchgesetzt wird in den einzelnen Praktiken, das wissen wir ja, aber du hast übrigens mal ein Kodex, auf den man sich berufen kann, wenn man meint, dass gegen den verstoßen wird.
Und es ist auch so ein bisschen die Vision, so der Science-Fiction, zumindest so ein Teil, wir hatten irgendwie Star Trek kurz erwähnt, auch in einem anderen Zusammenhang, aber die haben ja auch dann so die Föderation, die sind so die geeinte Welt im Rücken hat und jetzt gehen die Problematiken halt im Weltall los, aber so die Menschheit, die hat sich halt jetzt mal so auf irgendwas geeinigt und die alten Zöpfe alle abgeschnitten und klappe zu auf den Tod. Wir kümmern uns jetzt um was anderes.
Aber warum ist jetzt, habe ich jetzt überhaupt Poststrukturalismus so als das coole Ding, das man hier im CRE mal so bringen müsste, weil ich, wer jetzt nicht an dich ran gegangen hätte, gesagt, ja, wir wissen mal die Kritik der reinen Vernunft von Kant mal.
Oder sonst irgendeinen Seitenarm des philosophischen Widerstands.
Kant ist jetzt nicht gerade der Seitenarm.
Nein, aber der Poststrukturalismus ist es vielleicht. Oder du hättest ja auch noch mit was ganz Anderem ankommen können.
Genau.
Vielleicht bist du ja auch mit irgendwas ganz Anderem angekommen.
Nee, das war genau deswegen, wo ich gesagt habe, jetzt müsste man, wie so ein Fundament ist gelegt, jetzt müsste man eigentlich mal erklären, was ist eigentlich passiert? Warum hat das gewissermaßen, insbesondere in unserer Netzgemeinde, Netzkultur, Hackerkultur, eigentlich seinen Niederschlag gefunden? Und da ist besonders wichtig, der Genderdiskurs zu nennen. Und ich glaube, dem nicht wahrgenommen zu haben, wenn man halbwegs so in Twitter integriert ist, das ist schon schwer.
Lass mich noch kurz bevor wir auf diese neuen Aspekte eingehen. Ich glaube, das gehört noch so ein bisschen zur Zusammenfassung dazu. Denn das war ja dann auch so der Punkt, wo wir so ein bisschen ins Rennen geraten sind, so in den letzten 20 Minuten. Jetzt haben wir irgendwie über die Grundlagen geredet. Lass mal über das Thema reden. Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob ich das verstanden habe. Also der Poststrukturalismus, der jetzt nicht als Konzept daherkommt, sondern der kommt ja in Form von Personen an, unter anderem dieser von dir erwähnte Michelle Foucault. Genau. Gibt es noch andere Nennenswerte, zumindest in dem Zusammenhang erwähnt?
Es gibt nur so vier, fünf, vielleicht maximal sieben bekanntere Figuren und die sind auch alle schon seit 30, 40 Jahren dabei und in dem Sinne seit den Mitte der 80er, 90er Jahre in dem Sinne ist das gewissermaßen eigentlich eingepreist und die Caravane ist in einer gewissen Weise auch weitergezogen, weil einfach ist sehr viel in so Einzeldisziplinen eingeflossen ist und es musste jetzt auch nicht mehr so viel gesagt werden.
Zum Poststrukturalismus.
Zum Poststrukturalismus, genau. Das ist also eigentlich so ein bisschen so eine Art, man könnte jetzt bösewillig sagen, so eine Modephilosophie, die in den 70er und 80er Jahren besonders prominent war und durch den Tod und das doch eigentlich der Tod der meisten Protagonisten jetzt auch nicht mehr so relevant ist. Also Michael Foucault gehörte oder gehört eben gerade nicht dazu, aber er ist trotzdem wichtig, wird gewissermaßen, das ist ja eine Zuschreibung, die eher auch von Leuten kam, die, das ist ja nicht, es gibt keine poststrukturalistische internationale Philosophengemeinschaft, sondern das ist eine Zuschreibung, das ist ein Label, ein Etikett, dass man nur anhand von ein paar bestimmten Prinzipien gesagt hat, okay, der gehört dazu und der eben nicht. Meistens hat man es daran gesehen, dass jemand kein poststrukturalist ist, weil er besonders auf die geschimpft hat. Und jetzt so die wichtigsten Figuren, das ist Michel Foucault, das ist Jacques Derrida, dann ist es ein französischer Psychoanalytiker Jacques Lacan, dann gibt es noch so ein Duo, Deleuze und Guattari, es gibt, ich glaube, Julia Kristeva und quasi so der Nachlassverwalter des poststrukturalistischen Denkens ist dieser meistens inzwischen so als Philosophie-Casper Geschmähte Slavoj Zizek. So viel mehr fallen mir jetzt da auch nicht ein. Das gibt noch Francois Liotard, der hat 1976 im Auftrag der kanadischen Regierung im Zuge der Olympischen Spiele schon quasi so eine Kultur- und Gesellschaftsstudie gemacht und hat dabei quasi dieses Condition Postmodern quasi als Beschreibungsmerkmal der Zeit entwickelt. Und deswegen ist er so der programmatische Poster-Boy, was der aber sonst so im weiteren Sinne gemacht hat. Die großen Hauptwerke hat er meines Erachtens nicht gemacht, aber er hat quasi so das Ganze vielleicht auch durch diesen Olympiabass entsprechend in die internationale Debatte mit eingebracht. Es gibt ein paar wichtige Vorläufer vielleicht, die das ganze Feld erst entwickelt haben. Das ist Roland Barth. Den kann man nicht als Poststrukturalisten von der Methode, aber zumindest von der Haltung. Er hat was Trolliges. Also die Poststrukturalisten sind auch echte Philosophie-Trolle. Und es ist viel interessanter zu sehen, welche Widerstände sie gewissermaßen in der klassischen Philosophie hervorgerufen haben. Das ist viel interessanter als das, was sie wirklich geleistet haben.
Ja, das ist jetzt mal ein interessanter Begriff, den wir genauso einen Eindruck hatte ich jetzt auch. Ich will jetzt mal nicht vorlesen hier, sondern das vielleicht ein bisschen frei deuten. Also das Wesen, dieses Poststrukturalismus ist ja einerseits zu sagen, okay, Sprache bildet unsere Realität ab. Wir beschreiben unsere Welt durch das, was wir sagen. Andererseits bestimmt sie dadurch dann auch wiederum die Realität. Also irgendwie weiß ich, die schwarze Kürze so ein bisschen in den Schwanz und definiert sich irgendwie selbst und ist von daher dann wiederum auch komplett frei von irgendeiner absoluten Definition oder kurz gesagt, man kann damit überhaupt nichts sagen. Das ist ja schon fast so eine diskordische Feststellung, dass man braucht irgendwie, um die Sprache zu verstehen, die gesprochen wird, bräuchte man ja eigentlich eine Metasprache, wie man das auch bei der Programmierung herkennt. Man hat dann eben so seine klare Bedeutung dessen, was man da in den Programmcode irgendwie reinschreibt und die formuliert das oder auch ein Metaprotokoll, wie das in der Programmierung ist. Dann gibt es aber auch Programmiersprachen, die erlauben einem dieses Metaprotokoll dann auch nochmal zu programmieren und dann kommt man irgendwie vom Hölzchen aufs Stöckchen und irgendwie alles ist total durcheinander. Also die Kernaussage der Trollerei, dieser Philosophietrolle ist ja im Prinzip so, ihr dreht euch im Kreis, man kann eigentlich überhaupt nichts aussagen, alles ist vorbei und eure absoluten Werte und was irgendwie gut und böse ist, das ist alles Quatsch. Fragt sich natürlich, welches Gesellschaftsmodell sie jetzt eigentlich im Sinn haben, wenn sie diese Feststellung machen. Also am Ende sind wir ja dann immer noch da und denken und sind und wollen ja auch irgendwie uns auf irgendwas einigen, was ist jetzt der Entwurf, der dahintersteht.
Aber das ist ja auch dasselbe, was du mit Zern und mit der Suche nach dem Higgs-Teilchen hast. Also vielleicht dieses unglaubliche Vorlauf, den wir machen mussten.
Also du meinst den großen LAC, den Large Hadron Collider, die Größe, physikalische Installation, um eben einfach zu diesem letzten fehlenden Teilchen zur zur Bestätigung der heute noch aktuell gültigen Welttheorie zu kommen.
Und wenn man sich das mal so erklären lässt, dann ist das ja ein ähnlich aufwendiger Herleitungsprozess, den ich versucht habe, um dir quasi klar zu machen, worum geht es denn eigentlich bei diesem Poststrukturalismus eigentlich. Und in diesem naturwissenschaftlichen Kernphysikbereich steht uns das vielleicht noch ein bisschen näher. Aber eigentlich ist es ja auch ziemlich esoterisch, wenn man sich überlegt. Denn die Welt, die Physik funktioniert ja auch ohne, dass man jetzt weiß, gibt es das Higgs-Teilchen oder gibt es das nicht. Auch Atombomben, Laser und auch viele andere Dinge, die sogar effektiv mit der Quantentheorie und Quantenmechanik zu tun haben, funktionieren, ohne dass es genau klar ist, was jetzt diese große Weltformel eigentlich ist. Und das ist so ein bisschen dasselbe, was man auch zum Poststrukturalismus sagen kann. Ihr baut da einen gewaltigen, oder nicht nur den Poststrukturalismus, sondern der Sprachphilosophie generell sagen kann, ihr werdet nicht, könnt man jetzt sagen, ihr werdet mit all euren Denkgebäuden und all euren Beschleunigerringen, die ihr da virtuell in euren Hirnwindungen baut, letztlich nicht zu einem vernünftigen Ergebnis kommen. Vielleicht kommen auch die Physiker nicht zu einem vernünftigen Ergebnis, weil bisher ist ja hinter jedem Grenze immer wieder neue Sub-Teile und dahinter liegende Theorie-Gebäude wieder aufgetaucht. Was ich eigentlich auch ganz gut finde, weil es wäre ja furchtbar, wenn irgendwann mal alles erforscht wäre.
Ja, oder irgendeine absolute Wahrheit gefunden worden wäre, würde das sein.
Aber in der Philosophie ist es deswegen so problematisch, weil bestimmte ideologische Systeme sich auf solche Wahrheitsaktionen stützen und daraus auch ihre Legitimität ziehen. Also zum Beispiel mal die marxistische Theorie als wirklich eine sehr, sehr große Denkgemeinschaft, die auch nach wie vor in ihrem Ansatz, in ihren Grundelementen wirklich kluge und für die Erklärung aktueller Phänomene gute Lösungen bietet. Aber das sind jetzt nicht Lösungen, nicht im Sinne von absoluter Wahrheit, sondern Beschreibungen, die für eine bestimmte Zeit hinreichend sind, dass man sagen kann, okay, good point. Das Problem ist ja immer dann, wenn du quasi einen Wahrheitsanspruch hast, um dann auch noch die Welt zu verändern. Also bei Marx gibt es ja dieses berühmte Bon mot, die Philosophen haben die Welt nur verschieden interpretiert, es kommt darauf an, sie zu verändern. Und wenn aber diese Veränderung mit so einem Absolutheitsanspruch durchgesetzt wird, weil sie sich gewissermaßen auch im kleinsten und elementarsten Kern auf so einem Wahrheitsanspruch beruht, dann wird es eben gefährlich, weil das vergleichbar ist mit so einem Gotteskrieger. Es gibt also viele Leute, also das ist eine grundsätzliche Kritik am marxistischen Denken, dass es eigentlich so eine Art Säkular-Religion ist. Sie hat das göttliche Prinzip durch eine andere monokausale Erklärung ersetzt, nämlich dass die Menschen in ihrer Existenz um die Grundlagen streiten, um weiter existieren zu können und das ist gewissermaßen so ein Grundprinzip, das sich ständig durch die Geschichte hindurchzieht und vor ein paar Tagen war ich auch hier und habe gewissermaßen diese marxistischen Ansatz auf den Aufstieg der Piratenpartei angewandt und da klang das dann ja auch ganz einleuchtend. Ja, aber das ist mal eine situative Beschreibung und das ist nicht mehr als ein Gedankenspiel. Das soll jetzt nicht die Wahrheit sein und nach dem Motto jetzt müssen deswegen auch um die Geschichte abzukürzen, könnten also die Systemadministratoren auch quasi mit diktatorischen Herrschaftsanspruch ausgestattet werden und dann ist halt Pfeife an der Macht.
Kurzer Einwurf, die Sendung auf die du dich beziehst, ist die 19. Ausgabe von Logbuch Netzpolitik. Vielleicht ist auch mal ganz angemessen hier bei CRE mal ein paar Querverweise zu den anderen Programmen, die nicht CRE Sendungen sind, zu machen. Da warst du zu Gast und haben so ein bisschen über den Lauf der Zeit geredet, insbesondere die Realität der Piratenparteien im aktuellen Medienmassaker, dem sie ausgesetzt sind. Nicht wahr, weil eben einfach so dermaßen viel Aktivismus da gerade entsteht nach den erfolgreichen Wahlen im Saarland etc.
Ja, so ein monokausalen Ansatz, der ist auch irgendwie lebendig und solange man daraus nicht ein Geschichts- und Politprogramm macht, wie es eben dann die Bolschewiki in Russland dann gemacht haben, wäre der Marxismus auch nach wie vor eine großartige, vollkommen anerkannte politische Theorie.
Also meinst du, die Gotteskrieger des Marxismus sind dann unter anderem diese und die haben es auch wieder alle ins Verruf gebracht.
Ja, denn der Marxismus als solche hat dann eben auch sehr, sehr viele nach wie vor fruchtbare Weiterentwicklung erfahren und weil ja auch Marx selber während seiner Lebenszeit gesehen hat, dass schon Dinge, die er unter einem bestimmten Eindruck verfasst hat, dass sie sich im Laufe der Zeit ja verändert haben und das wurde umso stärker als halt die Marxisten des 20. Jahrhunderts gesagt haben, der Kapitalismus hat sich auch verändert, die Welt hat sich auch verändert und folglich müssen wir einfach mal die Grundannahme zwar nutzen, aber gleichzeitig schauen, wie diese Grundannahme mit der neuen Situation in der Welt funktioniert.
So, jetzt sind also die Poststrukturalisten sozusagen als Trolle der Philosophie dahergekommen, habt gesagt, so mit euren Aussagesystemen könnt ihr irgendwie überhaupt nichts bewirken.
Es war auch ein bisschen eher auch der Tonfall als jetzt der Inhalt. Der Ton macht die Musik. Dann die kulturellen Unterschiede zwischen der französischen Kulturwelt und der deutschen Romantik und gleichzeitig wiederum der angloamerikanischen Sprachphilosophie. Da war dann quasi auch so eine Unverständlichkeit, weil einfach die jeweiligen Kontexte sehr, sehr unterschiedlich waren und dadurch auch quasi, dass man so ein Schnittstellenproblem philosophisch ist. Ich kann da mal ein schönes Beispiel bringen. Vor etwa 20 Jahren gab es also wirklich so, ich glaube, eine 6-Semester- also was ich im letzten CRE gesagt habe, das ist quasi so das Exzept aus einem 6-semester langen Seminarreihe, die ich an der Frankfurter Uni zum Thema Texttheorie hatte, wo also wirklich mal diese gesamte Herleitung zum Poststrukturalismus jetzt mal ein bisschen allgemeiner als Texttheorie verstanden hergeleitet worden ist und in diesem Seminarbogen durfte ich zwei Referate halten. Eins über Derrida und Dekonstruktion und eins über Michel Foucault. Und bei Michel Foucault sagte dann auf einmal meine Krankheit gar kein richtiges Französisch. Also ich war aber trotzdem bei den Romanisten. Aus Gründen will ich jetzt gar nicht weiter bringen, aber dann sagte die Professoren zu mir, passen sie mal auf, es wird sehr voll werden. Bereiten sie sich gut vor. Bei deinem Vortrag? Normalerweise hast du in einem Referat so das Seminar, das sind so 30-40 Leute. Und ich sagte, unser Raum wird sehr eng werden, weil die ganzen Philosophen kommen.
Weil du über Foucault redest?
Weil ich über Foucault rede.
Wieso redet da sonst keiner über Foucault?
Der war verboten, in der philosophischen Fakultät der Frankfurter Uni, das war die kritische Schule der Marxisten. Die hatten also eine klare Hausordnung und da waren diese französischen Philosophen einfach außerhalb des Diskurs.
Über Trolle redet man nicht.
Die waren quasi in der Trolle-Ecke und gleichzeitig hatten natürlich die Leute ein Gefühl dafür, da ist was dran. Und das war, man macht ja so ein Seminar, um Schein zu bekommen.
Wie viel kam denn dann?
Es waren dann 70 oder 80 Leute, die standen dann da. Und das Referat war dann genauso scheitern als Chance verlaufen, dass ich natürlich nicht es geschafft habe, dieses eine Werk von Michael Foucault überhaupt wirklich anständig zu referieren, weil es dafür schon zu kompliziert ist und auch die ganzen Grundlagen zu erklären. Also man hätte eigentlich auch schon wieder so ein ganzes Semester gebraucht, nur um dieses eine Werk nahe zu bringen. Aber der Versuch wurde mir irgendwie, allein dass ich mich quasi dem Versuch gestellt hatte, wurde mir schon hoch angerechnet.
Okay, der Schein war dann in der Tasche.
Den Schein habe ich bekommen. Ich glaube, ich habe auch irgendwie gewonnen, weil ich hatte nämlich diese ganze poststrukturalistische Philosophie aus meiner Designer-Arbeit und aus meiner Werbetätigkeit interessiert, weil ich fand das interessant. Also generell mal Zeichentheorie dachte ich in meiner Naivität, das ist so was wie das theoretische Unterfutter, mit der man Werbung und Kommunikation betreibt. Das hände ich vielleicht auch nicht ganz falsch, aber ich glaube, in der Werbung gibt es nicht so viele Leute, die das auch so sahen. Und gleichzeitig hatte mich fasziniert die Architekturstilart des Dekonstruktivismus. Und das ist jetzt wirklich so eine ganz freche Aneignung gewesen von so ein paar, ich sage jetzt mal so verrückten Hippie und sonstigen Architekturleuten, die sich versucht haben, quasi diese poststrukturalistischen Texte in ihre Architektur umzusetzen, weil sie gesagt haben, jedes Haus, jede Architektur erzählt eine Geschichte. Sie ist damit wie ein Text zu behandeln und sie hat auch eine bestimmte kanonische Struktur und die werden wir jetzt sprechen, weil das klassische Haus, vielleicht auch mal so ein Schloss, das spricht eine Herrschaftssprache und die werden wir verändern und selbst diese moderne Architektur spricht letztlich trotz all ihrer Offenheit und Transparenz und Sonstiges, hat sie immer noch Herrschaftsansprüche und allein schon dieses Diktat des rechten Winkels und Pipapo. Also wir haben quasi wirklich versucht, das Programm der Theorie in gebaute Architektur umzusetzen. Und die Ironie an der Geschichte ist, dass sie sich auch wirklich erst in den 90er Jahren überhaupt anfangen durften zu bauen. Das heißt, sie haben über 20, 30 Jahre eigentlich nur schöne Entwürfe gemacht und erst mit der Durchsetzung eigentlich des poststrukturalistischen Programms in der Gesellschaft war dann auch erst die Zeit reif, dass sie ihre Dinge machen durften. Also Sahar Hadid ist eine pakistanische Architektin, die lange Zeit wirklich nur schöne abstrahierte Architekturzeichnungen gemacht hat und erst das Vitra Design Museum hat es ihr erlaubt, eine Feuerwehrwache zu bauen, die komplett dysfunktional zu sein scheint, aber das war der Startpunkt, der Durchbruch und seitdem macht sie also ganz viele Sachen. Sie hat das BMW-Werk in Leipzig gebaut, sie hat das Faino in Wolfsburg gebaut. Ich glaube, das sieht man sehr, sehr gut, wenn der ICE an Wolfsburg immer nicht haltend vorbei fährt. Faino, dieses aufgeständerte, naturtechnologische... Das ist so ein Erlebnis, Physik.
Wissenschaft zum Anfassen.
Und da sieht man auch so ein bisschen dieses querseitige, das auch so ein bisschen, so wie diese Theorie auch aufgefasst war, so wurde das gewissermaßen wirklich in diesen Linien übersetzt. Das steht quer zu allen Traditionen. Der Daniel Liebeskind ist auch ein dekonstruktivistischer Architekt, der das jüdische Museum hier in Berlin gemacht hat. Und das hat mich fasziniert, weil doch Ende der 80er, Anfang der 90er eben die ersten, nicht nur Entwürfe, sondern auch gebauten Sachen da waren. Mich hatte das fasziniert, weil ich ja auch diese Risszeichnung mache und quasi dieses utopische Moment in diesen Zeichnungen mich extrem inspiriert hat als Quelle für die eigenen Zeichnungen. Dadurch bin ich überhaupt an diese Sache rangekommen. Und in Frankfurt, wo ich zur damaligen Zeit gelebt habe, gab es das Deutsche Architektur-Museum. Und da wurden quasi schon Ende der 80er Jahre nur die reinen Pläne von diesen dekonstruktivistischen Architekten schon ausgestellt.
Sowas würden wir gerne mal bauen.
Ja und mich hat es einfach fasziniert als Zeichnung, gar nicht in dem Sinne als reale Architektur. Ich fand einfach schon die Ästhetik sehr gut, auch im Sinne von so einer futuristischen Ästhetik und Möglichkeiten-Design und ja, dadurch war es ein bisschen angefixt und als ich dann auf einmal merkte, es gibt gewissermaßen eine theoretische, philosophische Grundlage zu diesem dekonstruktivistischen Stil und darüber hinaus haben diese Architekten in ihren komischen Präsentationen, weil sie ja nicht bauen mussten, halt ständig diese Texte reingekopiert von Derrida und Foucault. Sie hatten nichts zu tun, nur Zeichnungen machen.
Ja, das Ganze hat auch philosophischen Unterbau.
Genau, den haben sie dann also wirklich extensiv benutzt und vielleicht auch dadurch quasi das Ganze popularisiert. Und aus diesem Naivität bin ich da halt rangegangen und deswegen auch bei dem CRE 91 fand ich das so schön, weil normalerweise hat man mit so einer soliden Allgemeinbildung doch das Gefühl, dass man, wenn ein verständiger Mensch einem was erklärt, dass man eigentlich dann irgendwann hinterher nach zwei, drei Stunden auch weiß, worum es geht. Und ich glaube zumindest, dass es bei CRE 91 dir nicht so ging.
Ich war auf jeden Fall nachhaltig verwirrt. Das hat auch ein bisschen was mit der Unsicherheit, ob der doch sehr vielen Aspekte, über die ich mir so bisher noch gar keine Gedanken gemacht habe, das war einfach in der Summe ein bisschen zu üppig. Aber zweitemal hören hilft.
Mir ging es damals, als ich quasi mit diesem sehr illustrativen, naiven Verständnis herangegangen bin, jetzt schaue ich mir mal die Philosophen dazu an, zu den Architekten, dass ich gemerkt habe, um was? Ja, so ein Spruch Derrida kritisiert zweieinhalbtausend Jahre abendländischen, metaphysischen Denkens und überbietet die, warte mal, ich habe hier einen schönen Klappentext. Und was war das hier? Derridas antimetaphysische Überbietungsvorsürs und die Konzeption eines entgrenzten Textes. Also solche Sachen wurden einfach nur so.
Da hat man noch so Flirren im Hirn.
Und was mich aber fasziniert hatte, war, dass ich natürlich aus einer Kulturtradition kam, wo man gar nicht auf die Idee kam, außerhalb eines zweieinhalbtausendjährigen philosophischen Mainstreams zu denken. Also, seit man jetzt Budist aus einem ganz anderen Kulturraum gekommen ist, dann guckt man ja von außen vielleicht auf die abendländische europäische Kultur.
Also, die Poststrukturalisten sind so ein bisschen die Philosophie-Punks?
Ja, aber viel wichtiger sind eigentlich so etwas wie Ethnologen des eigenen.
Des eigenen was?
Der eigenen Kultur. Dass sie einfach sagen, schaut doch mal auf unsere eigene Kultur und Wissenssysteme, wie wir vielleicht auf die Maya und ihre Kultur gucken oder auf die primitiven.
Also, wer ist das wir in dem Zusammenhang? Die postmoderne Gesellschaft oder?
Nein, das wir ist schon das große Ganze, die westliche Zivilisation. Sie sind ja Teil dieser Westen.
Na gut, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie groß die Klammer war.
Genau. Aber es gibt ja nun auch weltweit ja doch andere Traditionen und Denksysteme und durch den großen Erfolg des europäischen Modells, das ja quasi bis Mitte des 20. Jahrhunderts weite Teile der Welt einfach unter der Knute hatte, war natürlich die Motivation, sich quasi in so eine anders geartete, exzentrische Position zu begeben, um mal auf diese eigene Binnensystem, Wissenssystem zu schauen, natürlich sehr begrenzt. Also Ethnologie, das sind ja immer die anderen. Die Ethnologen haben inzwischen das gelernt und haben quasi diese Reflektion für sich aufgenommen und es gibt quasi eine europäische Ethnologie, wo man versucht, quasi das, was man bisher den anderen entsprechend den Blick, den man auf die anderen hatte, auf sich selber zu richten.
Das ist insofern ganz interessant, dass ich auch so ähnliche Züge der Auflösung von etablierten Bedeutungsgrößen beobachte, allein schon durch die Entwicklung in China. Ja, blödes Beispiel vielleicht, aber ich führe es einfach mal an, so unser Selbstverständnis von unserem Kapitalismus und seiner Verwebung mit so einem gewissen Freiheits- und Demokratiebegriff. Dann kommen da so die Chinesen und sagen, ach ja, hier so Kapitalismus, das scheint ja ganz gut zu funktionieren, das machen wir jetzt auch mal. Und dann stehen wir da so und so, ja und jetzt irgendwie Demokratie und hier Freiheits-Einzelnen, und nö, nö, lass mal. Muss nicht sein. Und dann prallen so, also so ein bisschen Unverständnis auf beiden Seiten, so die Chinesen immer so, sagen wir, wir müssen uns die ganze Zeit in das Hirn hier ficken, was, geht doch einfach mal weg. Und der Westen, der dann auch so einfach in dieser Blase des Selbstverständnisses bisher immer war und jetzt irgendwie beobachtet, dass andere Teile der Welt bestimmte Dinge sehr ähnlich machen. Teilweise auch komplett kopieren. Damit meine ich jetzt nicht Produkt-Kopien, sondern einfach auch Konzept-Kopien, aber andere eben auch vollkommen herauslassen und auch überhaupt keine Notwendigkeit sehen, weil offensichtlich ihre Herleitung auch eine ganz andere ist. Wir würden gar nicht auf die Idee kommen, das genauso zu machen.
Wobei sie ja verrückterweise als marxistisch nach wie vor sich auf den Marxismus berufende praktisches politisches System, das sich weiter entwickelt hat, aber ja eigentlich von ihrer Ideologie her einer westlichen, modernen Konzeption folgen. Und das hat für sie auch große Bedeutung. Also Aachen mit dem Geburtshaus, oder ich weiß nicht, Wohnsitz oder Arbeitssitz von Marx, das ist also, ich glaube, Aachen ist froh, dass jeder mittlere Kader der kommunistischen Partei Chinas da mal nach Aachen fahren muss. Das ist also deren Geschäftsmodell momentan.
Was ist denn Aachen?
Ne, Trier, Entschuldigung.
Was ist denn Trier?
Ich glaube, das Geburtshaus von Karl Marx. Und da pilgern die hin. Ja, das ist einfach, für die halt dort hat die Lehre den Ursprung gehabt, der nach wie vor Staatsräson ihres politischen Systems ist. Und das ist so irre, weil sie quasi einerseits so eine westliche Ideologie aufgenommen haben, aber natürlich mit ihrem kollektivistisch konfuzianischen, nationalistischen System quasi verbunden haben und daraus im Moment, wie du es ja auch gesagt hast, ein großartiges Selbstbewusstsein entwickeln.
So, jetzt kommen wir ja so auf diesen Punkt, mit was hat das alles mit unserer Zeit zu tun. In gewisser Hinsicht haben wir schon festgestellt, dass es eine ganze Menge mit unserer Zeit zu tun hat, weil eigentlich beschäftigt sich dieser Poststrukturalismus oder setzt oder ich weiß nicht, ob er sich damit beschäftigt oder ob er nicht in gewisser Hinsicht das selber mit eingeleitet hat. Wenn man jetzt sieht, es hat dann Auswirkungen in die Architektur und auf einmal sehen Museen genauso komisch im Verhältnis zu unserem etablierten Bild Haus aus, wie halt jetzt Chinas Wirtschaftssystem zu unserem etablierten Bild für Kapitalismus aussieht. Und reflektiert auch, was mir sehr daran gefällt, also ich mag diese Architektur irgendwie, weil die einfach auch so, die ist irre, die lässt sich nicht so sehr von diesen Zwängen leiten, sondern die sagt, okay, das muss auch in den Zwängen und den Anforderungen der Funktionalität muss es noch Freiheiten geben, die wir so bisher noch nicht gesehen haben. Und lustigerweise fand ich auch bei den Zeichnungen von so Science-Fiction-Modellen, also gerade so dieser Perirodan-Zeichenwelt, die du ja auch mitgeprägt hast, nicht wahr, da sind so diese ganzen Raumschiffe, die wollen einfach auch irgendwie ein gewisses exzentrisches Bild haben. Die sind nicht allein nur von irgendeiner vorstellbaren Funktion und einer damit verbundenen technischen Realität geprägt, sondern haben auch so eine eingebaute Exzentrik oder zumindest so einen gut aussehen wollen oder wie auch immer aussehen wollen, was ihnen so inhärent ist. Wenn man dann so mit so einer simplen technischen Sache rangeht, ist immer so dieses, guckst du dir das so, das kann gar nicht sein oder so würde das gar nicht aussehen, ja, nach unserem derzeitigen Blick und das hat dann auch so ein bisschen auch was mit Befreiung zu tun.
Und eben der Kommunikationsfunktion und die soll halt nicht traditionellen radionellen hierarchischen Mustern folgen. Da ist diese dekonstruktivistische Architektur in dem Sinne auch wieder hyperaufklärerisch, die einfach gesagt hat, naja, schönes Beispiel, die Deutsche Bundesbank. Kennst du vielleicht diesen quer liegenden Riegel mit zwei quasi so Treppenhauselementen, die das gesamte, diesen quer liegenden...
Wovon redest du jetzt? Von dem Gebäude?
Von dem Gebäude, ja.
Der Deutschen Bundesbank.
Der Deutschen Bundesbank. Und das ist quasi, es wird, also Architektur theoretisch wird das quasi als die maximal mögliche Reduktion eines Schlosses bezeichnet, weil es hat so ein Hauptgebäude und quasi so zwei Flügelteile. Also so modern das quasi daherkommt, hat es gewissermaßen noch so Anleihen an ein traditionelles, hierarchisches Herrschaftsarchitektur.
Wenn auch arg abstrahiert.
Total abstrahiert.
Ich muss sagen, ich blick gerade auf ein Foto, das hab ich das Gebäude live noch nie gesehen, ist ja wirklich sehr, ähm, schlecht.
Das ist die Betonbrutale per se. Aber jetzt so aus einer, ja, aus so einer, äh, diskursanalytischen, poststrukturalistisch beeinflussten Architekturkritik würde man jetzt sagen, ha, der Herrschaftsanspruch des Absolutismus zeigt, lässt sich erkennen, weil Geld ist nämlich die ultimative, neue Instanz, der sich alle gesellschaftlichen Kräfte nach auszurichten haben. Das ist ja eine Beschreibung, die hätte ja fast jetzt einen realen Wahrheitskern. Und da sieht man eben auch diese Tarnung von der, ich nenne es jetzt mal dieser Beton-Moderne, dass sie sich dann doch gewissermaßen bestimmten überkommenen Hierarchie und quasi auch so legitimatorischen Prinzipien aus einer ganz anderen Zeit, also der absolute König war quasi deswegen absolut, weil er als Ebenbild von Gottes Gnaden ausgesandt in dieser Welt gewissermaßen so der weltliche Stellvertreter der Allmacht Gottes war. Das ist quasi das ideologische Konstrukt hinter dem Absolutismus. Und wenn du das jetzt quasi in die Sphäre einer absoluten von der Politik unabhängigen Zentralbank weiterentwickelst und sei es nur in der Formensprache dokumentiert, die Bundesbank, dass sie sowohl von der Politik unabhängig ist, weil sie sitzt nicht in Bonn, sondern in Frankfurt. Sie sitzt am Finanzplatz, aber nicht in der Bankencity, sondern sie sitzt vier Kilometer außerhalb und guckt wie ein Wärter auf die zusammengeferchten Hochhäuser. Den selben Gestus versucht jetzt die EZB, was ja quasi die europäische Zentralbank, die baut sich jetzt lustigerweise vom dekonstruktivistischen Architekten-Kollektiv Corp Himmelblau entwickelten Wolkenkratzer, ein irgendwie in sich zerklüftet umeinander tanzenden Turm mit so einer etwas unklar dekonstruktivistischen Haltung, die auch ganz klar macht, dass die EZB anderen Prinzipien folgt, als die absolutistische Bundesbank. Das heißt, und da wird jetzt wieder das so schön, dass man quasi eigentlich in der Architektursprache ein Narrative herausfiltern kann und daraus wirklich so eine Erzählung entwickelt, die eine gewisse Evidenz hat zum wirklich kolportierten oder zum kolportierten Geschehen, im realen politischen oder finanzpolitischen Raum.
Ich schau gerade auf dieses Gebäude und versuche gerade mal so ein bisschen schlauer daraus zu werden. Da sind alle Rindringen ein bisschen klein, aber es sind so zwei...
So um sich einander tanzende Türme und sie sind jetzt so in Frankfurt so auf halber Höhe und sie sind auch und sie haben auch diese Distanz zur Banken City aufgenommen, die Europäische Zentralbank hat momentan den alten, das alte Hochhaus der Bank für Gemeinschaft übernommen. Das war ursprünglich mal das quasi der dritte Weg der Gewerkschaften, die im Kapitalismus so ein eigenes Ding drehen wollten und damit dann ja in den 80er Jahren endgültig gescheitert sind und die EZB sitzt halt quasi jetzt zwischen den ganzen anderen Bankinstituten, die sie eigentlich kontrollieren soll und sie muss jetzt gewissermaßen eine Position auch im öffentlichen Raum einnehmen, der einfach diese Kontrollfunktion, diese Exzentrik und ihre herausgehobene Position sowohl gegenüber den Banken als auch gegenüber der Bundesbank klar macht, sodass die jetzt in so einer Art Triangel sich alle gegenseitig beobachten.
Bist du wirklich der Meinung, dass denen das selbst so bewusst ist?
Das ist vollkommen egal. Das ist nämlich genau poststrukturalistisches Argumentieren, weil der Poststrukturalismus ja auch sagt, es gibt keinen Autor mehr, sondern nur noch den Text. Und da sind wir jetzt ganz modern mit dem, was z.B. MS-Pro mit Kontrollverlust meint. In dem Moment, wo du etwas nach außen legst, hast du keinerlei Kontrolle mehr, wie es interpretiert wird. Du kannst zwar deine Interpretation zur Verteidigung deiner möglichen Intentionen reinbringen, aber das ist nur noch eine möglicherweise herausgehobene oder vielleicht auch nur herausgehobene wahrnehmbarere Stimme unter allen anderen Interpreten. Denn wir haben jetzt vorhin unser Gespräch noch mal von vor dreieinhalb Jahren gehört und letztlich ist es uns ja auch fremd geworden. Das heißt, wir haben den Text ja auch quasi, das gesprochene Wort, den Text also auch wieder neu gehört und haben uns ja nicht quasi identisch als Autoren dieses damaligen Gesprächs gesehen, sondern wir sind ja jetzt Interpreter, wir sind Hörer unseres eigenen Textes gewesen, aber nicht mehr Autoren. Einfach, weil auch die Zeit so lange und wir da vieles vergessen haben. Und deswegen ist also die Auslegungskunst, auch die steht vor der Kunst, etwas zu schreiben, etwas zu produzieren. Und auch das ist natürlich ein maximaler Angriff auf den, auf das...
Der Interpreter wird sozusagen wichtiger als der Autor. Dann sind wir wieder bei der Software, man kann ja dann auch schreiben und man kann meinen, was es eigentlich tun soll, aber entscheidend tut natürlich der Rechner.
Und da sind wir auch an dieser selben Bewegung wiederum. Nicht ich spreche die Sprache, sondern die Sprache spricht mich. Und die Sprache ist nämlich als System, ich wachse in diesem Sprachsystem auf und kann irgendwann vielleicht innerhalb des Systems durch Sprachspiele auch einen besonderen, eigenständigen Ausdruck in ihr ausüben. Aber ich komme nie aus ihr raus und ich komme auch nie in diese exzentrische Position, wo sich jetzt die EZB oder die Bundesbank gerne so als Diskurswächter sehen wollte, weil das ist eine Fiktion des des des Politischen, dass man im politischen Raum noch so tun kann oder vielleicht sogar real eine eine Wärter- und Wächterrolle einnehmen kann, aber in der Sprachpraxis ist die nicht möglich. Und deswegen ist es also vollkommen egal, ob der Bundesbanker oder der Architekt, also vollkommen klar ist, dass die Leute von Coop Himmelblau mit all ihrem theoretischen Unterfutter der letzten 40 Jahre, dass sie in jedem Fall diese Dreieckskonstellation ganz genau und bewusst sehen und dass sie auch gedrängt haben, dass genau dieser Bauplatz für diesen EZB Tower in Frankfurt genutzt wird, der auf dem Gelände einer alten Markthalle stattfindet, die dann auch nochmal so durchschnitten wird, diagonal durch den Eingangshalle. Das ist auch quasi zu offener Bedeutungsebene hochinteressant, weil also quasi das Marktgeschehen wird gewissermaßen wie durch so einen Fallbeil, das alte traditionelle Marktgeschehen durch das vertikale Instrument des quasi entfesselten Finanzkapitalismus durchschnitten. Die Traditionen werden gekappt und das Ganze nur noch als symbolisches Historienraum quasi nur noch dargestellt. Also dort dürfen dann die Angestellten der EZB in einem angenehmen Ambiente-Kantinen-Tätigkeits-Ausüben.
Kommen wir nochmal ein bisschen weg von der Architektur als einzigen Ausdruck. Jetzt speziell das Dekonstruktionismus.
Ja, also die Dekonstruktion ist das Verfahren und in der Architektur, die Anwendung ist die Dekonstruktivistische.
Richtig, und davon wollte ich jetzt mal ein bisschen weg, um einfach auch mal ein bisschen andere Echoes zu sehen. Jetzt können wir vielleicht nochmal kurz anknüpfen, was du eingangs sagen wolltest. Du hast die Gender-Debatte angeführt als Beispiel.
Die Gender-Debatte ist wichtig für die Position generell von Minderheiten innerhalb einer Gesellschaft. Also Frauen sind ja keine Minderheit, aber sie haben ihre Position im gesellschaftlichen Gewebe als eine minoritäre und nicht so wichtige erfasst und halten das für falsch und im emanzipatorischen Prozess versuchen sie diese minoritäre Position zu verlassen und in eine gleichberechtigte zu kommen. Warum ist jetzt diese poststrukturalistische Perspektive so befruchtend für diese Bewegung? Übrigens auch für die Bewegung der Schwarzen in Amerika. Für die Schwulen, für die transsexuellen Eichhörnchen. Alle haben das Problem, dass sie in einem Sprachsystem und nicht nur in einem Sprachsystem, sondern jetzt geweitert in einem Kulturraum aufwachsen, der als, wo alle Wahrheiten, relativen Wahrheiten jetzt gesehen, also das, was in dieser Gesellschaft gilt, durch Sprachstrukturen und Sprachmuster vermittelt wird. Durch Narratives. Das ist gut, das ist schlecht, das ist böse. Du bist eine Schlampe, wenn du mit mehr als einem Mann schläfst. Also es gibt also quasi schon ständig, eigentlich in dem Raum, der einen prägt, auf einmal das Gefühl, ich selber habe aber ganz andere Dinge, die mir wichtig sind. Und jetzt befinde ich mich quasi in einem Dilemma, dass dieser Sprachraum, der mich bestimmt, auf einmal in bestimmten zentralen Aussagen in Widerspruch zu meinen eigenen sich entwickelnden Wünschen, Begehren und Praktiken sich befindet. Und deswegen ist halt diese Gender-Debatte auch so wichtig auf der Sprachebene. Deswegen das Binnen-I, so blödsinnig das, das ist so ein Hauptkampfplatz, weil es geht um Sprache, weil die Identität, die man von außen beim Aufwachsen innerhalb des Sprachsystems erfährt, die auf einer anderen Ebene aber querliegen zu den eigentlich minoritären identifikatorisch als wichtig erachteten Zuschreibungen. Also ich bin schwul, aber überall sind nur Männerfiguren zu sehen, die heterosexuell sind und um Frauen kämpfen. Wo bin ich denn da? Wo gibt es denn mal einen Helden, der um seinen Freund kämpft, um mit dem zusammen zu sein? Diese Minderheiten sehen sich also nicht repräsentiert und da ist es halt so befruchten, dass sie gesagt haben, ja, auch diese Mehrheitsgesellschaft beruht ja nur auf Sprache. Das sind keine Wahrheiten, sondern das sind Konventionen und dadurch, dass man jetzt quasi aus diesen Minderheiten-Positionen versucht, quasi durch Code-Injections diese Annahmen und relativen Wahrheitssystemen durch eine Gegenwahrheit zu anzufüttern, entsteht auf einmal diese ganze Gender-Debatte, wo jetzt auch jetzt die Piraten wieder drin sind, weil die überwiegend männlich, heterosexuell, weiß-geprägte Mehrheits-Piraten-Sozio-demografische Schicht quasi von diesen Minderheiten aus dem feministischen, netz-queeren Lager sich auf einmal mit Fragestellungen konfrontiert sind, wo sie sagt, nö, wir sind doch eigentlich, jeder hat doch hier Rechte und jeder kann sich doch hier ausdrücken, aber das Problem ist, dass die Minderheiten sich wiederum in dieser Mehrheitssprache nicht wiederfinden. Und das klagen sie ein. Und weil sie gelernt haben, dass die gesellschaftliche Mainstream-Welt kommuniziert mit diesen bestimmten Mustern. Und wenn man sich in diesen Mustern nicht wiederfindet, ist man am Rand. Und dann gehört man irgendwo auch nicht dazu. Und quasi dies aufgebrochen zu haben, weil das war vorher gar nicht, also im 17., 18. Jahrhundert, waren das gewissermaßen Probleme, die innerhalb der Sprache, innerhalb der Wahrheitssysteme, also die Sprache informiert über die gesellschaftlichen Konventionen. Und das, was als wahr erachtet wird, wird über Sprache vermittelt, in den Ritualen der Gesellschaft, in den Institutionen und so weiter. Das wurde überhaupt nicht thematisiert. Du hast in der französischen Revolution, gibt es keine Nebenkommunikä der schwulen Jakobiner oder sowas. Das ist noch außerhalb jeder politischen Aktivität. Und diese Emanzipationsbewegungen versuchen halt einen Einschluss zu bekommen und mitzureden in diesem großen Gewebe, das dann immer wieder einen neuen Konsensus innerhalb der gesellschaftlichen Teil- Wahrheitssysteme erzeugt. Michael Foucault war quasi derjenige, der wirklich da ganz erhellend gesagt hat, jawohl, man muss quasi im Diskurs sich einbringen und dadurch entstehen auch Machtkerne. Und man sieht, dass momentan auch wieder mit dem Aufstieg der Piratenpartei, aber auch mit den ganzen sozialen Bewegungen der 60er-, 70er-, 80er-Jahre, in dem Moment, wo man Stimme ergreift, in diesem Diskurs wahrnehmbar wird. Das muss auch kein friedlicher Diskurs sein, weil auch Gewalt ist ja Kommunikation. Verhalten sich alle anderen diskursiven Mächte zu diesen neuen Spieler. Und wenn man entsprechend laut auftritt, wird man quasi als Minderheiten, als Teil macht, gewisserweise im Diskurssystem, das dann irgendwann wahrscheinlich auch zu so einer Art Gleichgewicht finden will, berücksichtigt. Das ist quasi dann der Respekt.
Gut, aber wenn die Poststrukturalisten jetzt sagen, es gibt keine allgemeingültige Sprache und was du sagst, kann so interpretiert werden, was du sagst, kündet ja eigentlich im Prinzip auch von einer Welt, in der einfach für jeden ein eigener Sprachkodex gilt, dann könnte man ja auch damit zufrieden sein, dass die einen so reden und die anderen so. Trotzdem ist es ein Kampf um die Deutungshoheit des Begriffes oder auch um den eigentlichen Begriff, der für einen bestimmten Bereich steht. Das ist ja auch Teil der politischen Auseinandersetzung, und damit natürlich auch Teil der Macht-Auseinandersetzung. Wir fallen jetzt zwei Beispiele rein hier, so aus unserem Kulturkreis auch. Als dieser Kampf aufgenommen wurde vom Club gegen die, ja, und wie heißen sie denn jetzt? Die Geräte, mit denen man wählt, anstatt dass man einen Zettel nimmt und auf einem Blatt Papier ein Kreuz macht.
Die Wahlmaschinen.
Genau, so. Das war nämlich der im Raum stehende Begriff. Die Wahlmaschine. Und was hat man so im Kopf, wenn man hört, Maschine? Maschine ist das so Zahnräder, Hebel, so man kennt irgendwie so diese Automaten, da zieht man so einen Hebel oben, hat man eine Münze reingeschmissen und unten hat sie dann irgendwie ein neues Bild drauf geprägt. Kannst jede Münze reinschmeißen, unten kommt immer dasselbe Bild raus. Die selbe Handlung erzeugt immer dasselbe Ergebnis. Das ist irgendwie so diese Assoziationskette, die an der Stelle durch diesen Begriff allein schon geschmiedet wurde. Dann kam der politische Kampf, wurde dann über das Wort geführt. Vielleicht war die ganze Geschichte schon gewonnen in dem Moment, als man die Deutungshoheit über das Thema dadurch entlangt hat, dass man eben gesagt hat, wir nennen das Wahlcomputer. Weil jeder, der irgendwie weiß Computer, da ziehe ich immer mal einen Hebel und es kommt jedes Mal was anderes dabei raus. Ist das dann auch schon dekonstruiert? Ist das der Kampf ums Wort? Man könnte ja auch sagen, hier in der Genderdebatte ist ja eigentlich egal, wie man es nennt.
Ja, aber du wächst ja als kleiner Mensch in dieser Sprachgemeinschaft auf. Und wenn diese Sprachgemeinschaft einfach die Zuordnung nur in Junge und Mädchen und Heteronormativität kennt, dann bist du ab einem gewissen Punkt in deiner Entwicklung, fühlst du dich ausgeschlossen und dieses ausgeschlossen sein ist traumatisch. Und das ist ein Kampf und das ist ein Verlust und ein Schmerz, den man hinterherläuft. Ja, verstehe ich.
Ich bin nur deshalb da kurz drauf rein, weil du ja gesagt hast, die Poststrukturalisten sagen, naja, jeder Text muss für sich gesehen werden und es gibt ja gar kein allgemeine Wertgebildung mehr. Das würde dem ja jetzt widersprechen. Ja, jetzt ist es ja so, okay, jetzt bekämpfen um diesen Begriff, weil wir wollen einen gemeinsamen Wert haben. Das ist ja dann eigentlich eher das Lied der Nicht-Poststrukturalisten.
Hier müssen wir jetzt einfach mal nochmal zwischen diesen philosophischen Poststrukturalisten, die in so einer Art Elfenbein zerren, quasi die letzten Wahrheitspartikel gegeneinander schleudern, um zu gucken, gibt es hinter der Wahrheit das große Nichts. Und das andere ist der quasi Mensch, der Diskurspraktiken mit so einer quasi durch die poststrukturalistische Sichtweise in der Welt des Common Sense vertritt. Wo es ja durchaus Machtstrukturen gibt, von dem man sagt, die wollen mir übel, den muss ich gegenüber treten. Also bei Michel Foucault ist es zum Beispiel ganz evident, er ist schwul. Er war schwul, er ist einer der ersten prominenten AIDS-Opfer gewesen 1984, als die Krankheit überhaupt noch nicht draus war. Also wesentliche Teile der gesamten Arbeit von Michel Foucault geht es um die Probleme, warum Gesellschaften Ausschluss-Tätigkeiten gegenüber bestimmten Teilgruppen ausübt. Und das ist vielleicht auch sein eigener biografischer Urtrieb.
Und was war da seine Schlussfolgerung?
Er hat keine. Der Foucault hat quasi ein großes Programm, das sich aber über die Jahre hinweg verändert hat. Der hat kein geschlossenes System entwickelt, sondern eigentlich war er der mit den guten Fragen. Und er hat ein paar interessant trollige Antworten gegeben, die aber als solche eher interessant waren als wahr. Also er bezieht sich zum Beispiel in seinem Buch Die Ordnung der Dinge auf einen Ausspruch von von Borges, der auch so als der quasi Erfinder des Internets gilt, bevor das Erfinder des World Wide Web gilt, weil er sich eine Art Universal-Bibliothek gedacht hat, die so auf einer permanenten Verlinkung basiert, obwohl er das gar nicht elektronisch gemeint hat, sondern mehr so als ein Geistesgebilde. Und der hatte irgendeine Geschichte gemacht, dass es angeblich gäbe es in der chinesischen Tradition so eine ganz andere Taxonomie von Tieren. Und diese Taxonomie hat quasi so, es gibt gefiederte Tiere, es gibt Tiere, die beißen, es gibt Tiere, die dem Kaiser gehören, es gibt Tiere, wo man auf einmal merkt, holla, das ist doch ein Kategorienfehler, aus unserer Sicht. Aber wenn jemand behauptet, das wäre jetzt die Kategorisierung TM, die in einem bestimmten Narrative funktioniert, offensichtlich in der chinesischen Kategorie, wo gewissermaßen Tiere des Kaisers eine Kategorie außerhalb oder jedenfalls eines eigenen Rechts sind, die zumindest mal neben den Gefiederten und denen, die beißen, gibt es eben die des Kaisers. Ja, ist da...
Mit Bochers meinst du diesen argentinischen Schriftsteller, der ist nicht, also nicht im einigen Sinne, Philosoph, der hatte auch Anschauungen.
Das ist ja bei den, da ja alles Text ist, gibt es auch keine, das macht es ja auch wiederum für die konventionelle, orthodoxe Philosophie so schwierig, weil die ganzen oder viele Texte auch des Poststrukturalismus geschrieben sind wie Dichtung, weil sie ja quasi auf Sprachspielen aufbauen und sagen, verdichtete Sprache ist ja gewissermaßen schon Metasprache in sich, weil es eine Sprache ist, die nicht nur rein kommunizieren will, sondern auf einen bestimmten Kunstfertigkeit versucht, sich selber schon darzustellen und als dieses, diese, damit ist es schon so eine Spezialsprache, die viel interessanter ist und vielleicht auch geeigneter ist, metasprachliche Probleme auszudrücken. Und deswegen sind viele Post-, also es gibt irre Geschichten, insbesondere von Deleuze und Guattari, die halt aus dieser psychoanalytischen Erkenntnis kommen. Also dieser Lacan hat versucht eigentlich aus seiner Sicht die Psychoanalyse wieder zurück zu Freud zu bringen und zu bestimmten Grundannahmen von Freud. Und da geht es ja auch quasi um diese Bewusstwerdung des Kindes, ja. Und wie es mit bestimmten Mustern in der Familie umgeht. Und da sind wir natürlich genau an diesem Punkt, wo Sprache und Zivilisation und bestimmte Herrschaftsmuster auftauchen. Und auch diese Verletzungen, die dann durch diese Psychoanalyse gewissermaßen irgendwann sichtbar und auch artikulierbar gemacht werden und damit sowas wie eine Heilung ermöglichen. Und ich finde diesen, ich werde jetzt mal ganz kurz nach diesem Text suchen, weil ich ihn einfach so irre finde und dann noch mal versuchen, in der deutschen Übersetzung, wenn es denn überhaupt hier gibt, ihn vorzulesen. Das ist nur so ein kurzer Absatz, weil in diesem Text von Deleuze und Guattari versucht, ist der Text quasi, setzt sich in die in die Person des Kindes.
Kannst du mal sagen, wer die beiden sind?
Kann ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht.
Aber es ist jetzt auch Leute, die dem Poststrukturalismus zugerechnet werden.
Ja, genau, genau. Und von ihm gibt es ein wichtiges Werk, das ist die Mille Plateau, die 1000 Plattformen, auf denen gewissermaßen die Gesellschaft ist in 1000 Teilgesellschaften strukturiert. Und das andere Wichtige ist das Anti Ödipus. Dass die Praxis des Schreibens eher an der Dichtung dran ist und teilweise gar nicht mehr zu unterscheiden ist von einer Wissenschaftssprache, die als solche gewissermaßen sich in so eine formale Herrschaftssituation begibt. Das ist wieder dieses Deutsche Bank und EZB-Problem. Dass die Wissenschaft, also die Philologie, tut so, als hätte sie eine Wächterfunktion gegenüber den Texten, die das Objekt ihrer Untersuchung sind. Mit welcher Rechtfertigung darf denn ein philologischer Text sich überhaupt als andere Form von Kategorie, von Text gegenüber einem literarischen Text begreifen? Also das sind jetzt mal wirklich in der Praxis diese Geschichten, was es heißt, keine exzentrischen Positionen, keine außerhalb eines bestimmten Systems befindlichen Positionen einnehmen zu dürfen.
Klingt so auch ein bisschen wie eine angemessene Realität in Bezug auf das Internet. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt versuchen würde, da alles mit einem Maß zu messen, würde man ja auch nirgendswo hinkommen. Das hat man sehr schön bei dieser Netzsperrendiskussion gesehen, wo dann Leute sich eben auch aufschwingen und sagen, das fällt unter die Kategorie böse, weil da wird ja über X geredet und X ist etwas, womit wir ein Problem haben. Auch wenn hier nicht X gemacht wird, aber über X geredet wird, könnte ja das Reden über X auslösen und das muss verhindert werden. Deswegen müssen wir das verbannen.
Wo ich gerade beim Mille Plateau war.
Das finde ich eigentlich überhaupt das Internet, überhaupt die Konstruktion schlechthin.
Deswegen passte es auch so gut, dass genau in dem Moment, wo Poststrukturalismus sich insbesondere in Amerika, in den Cultural Studies, als so eine eigene, quasi als das Werkprogramm des Poststrukturalismus und der Dekonstruktion entwickelt hat, also aus der Philologie heraus gesagt hat, alles ist Text, also können wir nicht mehr klassische Literaturwissenschaft betreiben, sondern wir müssen Kulturwissenschaft werden. Weil wir können gewissermaßen, wenn alles Text ist, können wir ja auch quasi zwischen einem Buch und einer institutionellen Praxis, die ja in Normen und Regeln und Gesetzen beschrieben ist, das ist alles Literatur. Damit ist die gesamte Welt jetzt unser Forschungsgegenstand. Und dieses Programm ist so in der Mitte der 80er Jahre wahrscheinlich in den amerikanischen Universitäten entstanden. Und ist dann quasi in den 90ern über die Pop-Kultur-Auseinandersetzung auch in den deutschen Universitäten als eigenständiges irgendwas mit Medienfach dann so angekommen. Und da haben sich halt insbesondere diese Sensibilitäten für minoritäre Positionen entwickelt, die dann auch zu diesem Political Correctness-Syndrom geführt hat. Also das PC-Sprechen ist gewissermaßen eine programmatische Ableitung aus diesen Diskurs-Praktiken oder Diskursanalysen des poststrukturalistischen Denkens. Dass man sagt, Sprache ist ein Herrschaftsinstrument. Und wir müssen ganz genau schauen, wie Sprache in der Praxis eingesetzt wird. Und da, wo wir das Gefühl haben, dass Sprachpraxis Minderheiten ausschließt und sie diskriminiert, müssen wir eine Gegensprache entwickeln. Und das führt natürlich dann wieder zu einer sehr normativen Sprachsituation, also das Pendel schwenkt dann um in das Problem, das darf man doch noch mal sagen dürfen. Und das ist auch nicht gelöst. Das sieht man ja mit vielen Shitstorms und Trollereien, die ständig auf Twitter passieren. Gibt es auch einen grandiosen Roman, The Human Stain, ich glaube von Philip Roth, auch noch mal verfilmt vor einiger Zeit, wo ein Professor in einer Literatur-Vorlesung das falsche Wort verwendet, nämlich, da sind Leute, die nie zu seinem Seminar kommen. Und dann fragt er, have anybody seen this spooks ever? Und da wird ihm dann vorgehalten, weil diese zwei Leute, die da fehlen, das sind zwei schwarze Studenten. Und dann wird ihm vorgehalten, dass er quasi eine rassistische Bemerkung gemacht hat, weil Spook wäre eine pejorative Zuschreibung für Schwarze.
Heißt aber auch genauso Gespenster, Leute, die irgendwie nicht so richtig greifbar sind.
Genau. Und dann sagt er, die sind aus Spooks. Also die sind offensichtlich nur hier gemeldet, aber nie da. Und dann wird er vor so einer Wahrheitskommission in seiner Universität geführt. Und dann holt er also die Oxford Dictionary raus und sagt, Spook heißt Gespenst, dies, jenes und in dem Zusammenhang eben Figuren, die nicht greifbar sind. Wo ist denn das Problem? Und da wird ihm gesagt, das Problem ist nicht du und deine Intentionalität, deines Ausdrucks, sondern so, wie es verstanden worden ist. Und Affirmative Action heißt natürlich, dass diejenigen, die bisher immer durch die Machtsprache der weißen, alten Männer beeinflusst worden sind, natürlich jetzt, wenn sie sich schon angegriffen fühlen, ein besonderes Recht haben, quasi auch ihre etwas abseitige Interpretation hat gewissermaßen ein höheres Gewicht als deine Wortwahl und Intention. Und deswegen wirst du jetzt quasi wegen Rassismus, gibt es dann so ein Peer-to-Peer, gibt es dann so ein Peer-Abstimmung, weil jeder hat...
Weil wir der Meinung sind, dass es das gemeint haben könnte.
Genau. Das die Point an der Geschichte ist aber, dass dieser weiße Professor gar kein weißer ist, sondern ein schwarzer, der außerordentlich helle Hautfarbe hat und der, weil er rhetorisch und von der ganzen Bildung her so gut ist, dass er es gemerkt hat bei irgendeiner Zuschreibung, ich glaube er schreibt sich irgendwo ein, Sozialkasse und so und dann fragt ihn jemand dieses Gender-Käschen, dieses Racist-Käschen. So, diese Checkbox. Normalerweise ist es so, dass er mit seiner ganzen schwarzen Familie irgendwo hingegangen ist und da ist dann schon klar, dass er das Kind, weil es gibt ja, die sehen sich ja ähnlich, aber in einer Form ist er halt, wenn er alleine ist, hat er halt einfach nicht diese schwarz-afrikanischen Züge und das merkt er in dem Moment. Und dann beginnt er diesen Verrat an seiner eigenen Identität, indem er einfach sagt, okay, wenn jetzt hier der Beamte mich nicht von vornherein als African American einschätzt, dann mach ich mich doch einfach zum Caucasian. Und damit ist er offiziell halt ein Weißer. Und 30 Jahre später aber bricht seine gesamte akademische Existenz zusammen, die er mit einem einzigen Wort, indem er diese Lebenslüge nur hätte aufbrechen müssen, indem er gesagt hat, ja, ich kann gar kein Rassist sein, weil ich bin ja selber schwarz. Genau. Das ist ein herrlicher Roman und auch die Verfilmung ist ganz gelungen dazu.
Sind denn jetzt diese Hardcore-Poststrukturalisten-Geeks, die so in ihrem Kämmerchen auch noch die letzte Bedeutungsvarianz, sozusagen die String-Theorie der Buchstaben-Bedeutung, da irgendwie versuchen auszubaldovern, ist das dann sozusagen die Relevanz in 50 Jahren oder siehst du da heute jetzt schon konkrete Ergebnisse? Ich meine, wir hatten jetzt Gender-Minderheiten-Debatte so ein bisschen als ein Beispiel. Ich vermute mal, wir könnten jetzt auch noch, oder halt auch so diese Machtfrage, siehst du noch andere Auswirkungen, die es schon gibt oder siehst du noch Auswirkungen, die das jetzt konkret haben kann oder ist deren Tätigkeit eigentlich eh egal? Wir reden jetzt hier eher abstrakt von so einem Phänomen poststruktureller Auflösung. Alles, was vorher irgendwie klare Strukturen hatte, das verschwindet, so wie die Moderne da war und das jetzt auch in der Postmoderne so langsam vor sich hin dampft. Müssen wir einfach so, Stichwort Kontrollverlust, einfach damit leben, dass die Dinge alle nicht mehr so sind, wie sie scheinen. Ich meine, das ist ja im Prinzip so eine diskordische Zukunft, die wir hier an die Wand malen. Ist das jetzt schon die Gegenwart? Wie muss man das sehen?
Also was mich besonders betroffen macht, ist eigentlich, dass diese Auseinandersetzung mit Poststrukturalismus in dieser Fachöffentlichkeit als philosophisches Spezialgebiet verspätet jetzt sicherlich auch in den orthodoxen philosophischen Instituten anerkannt ist. Vor 20 Jahren, wie gesagt, diese absurde Situation, dass da Doktoranden und so Hive Potentials aus dem Philosophenturm flüchten, zu den Romanisten gehen, damit so was über aktuelle zeitgenössische Philosophie von einem Studenten, der sein erstes Referat hält, der den Originaltext nicht mal lesen kann, weil er kein Französisch kann, vorträgt. Also es ist ja eine untragbare Situation. Gleichzeitig finde ich, dass sehr viele Beschreibungen unserer aktuellen Welt mit den Begrifflichkeiten und den Instrumentarien und vor allen Dingen auch diesen Diskurs, Praktiken, klingt ein bisschen blöd, aber diesen vorsichtig tastend immer sich selbst gegenwärtig sein, was sage ich da eigentlich? Es ist mehr so eine Haltung, immer zu prüfen, mit welcher Sprache spreche ich eigentlich? Dass es eigentlich ein gutes Instrumentarium ist, um in den aktuellen politischen und gesellschaftlichen Gegebenheiten sich eine gewisse Orientierung zu verschaffen, das gleichzeitig aber eben in der allgemeinen Öffentlichkeit und auch in der informierten Öffentlichkeit, also nicht der Zeitleser, sondern der Zeitredakteur. Und auch jemand wie du, der wirklich alle Antennen offen hat, dass das quasi eine theoretische Grundlage ist, die du vorher gar nicht verinnerlicht hattest. Und das hat mich eigentlich betroffen gemacht. Das war auch so ein bisschen das Programm, dass ich eigentlich sagen wollte, Holla, es gibt da gewissermaßen eine Art Denkschule, ein Denksystem, das sehr vieles entwickelt hat, einen Instrumentenkasten, wenn man den, und Instrumenten vielleicht eher zur Beobachtung, denn zur Manipulation, wobei natürlich dann ja auch die Nähe irgendwann die Beobachtung zur Manipulation führt. Aber da sind wir ja gar nicht, wir bewegen uns eher auf so einer Makro-Ebene, dass man einfach mal versucht, verschiedene Phänomene unter, mit diesem Beobachtungsinstrumentarium sich Klarheit zu verschaffen, um einfach nur das Bewusstsein zu bekommen, was geschieht eigentlich in der Welt. Und da glaube ich, dass alle anderen Erklärungsmuster wesentlich kontaminierter sind, weil sie immer schon aus einer bestimmten Ideologie heraus sprechen. Und andere, die quasi solche, ich sag mal, eher poststrukturalistischen Ansätze oder die Instrumente, die daraus abgeleitet sind, einsetzen, aber wiederum nicht über die grundsätzliche theoretische Fundierung Bescheid wissen, was eben im Bereich PC-Debatte, Queer-Policy, Heteronormalitäts-Dissen quasi dazu führt, dass aus meinem Empfinden die Instrumente eingesetzt werden, aber man weiß gar nicht, woher sie kommen und vielleicht werden sie auch falsch oder zumindest in einem falschen Maße oder auch an der falschen Stelle benutzt.
Aber was Instrumentenkasten zur Beobachtung? Ich meine, gut, der aber nicht unbedingt Manipulation bedeutet. Auf der anderen Seite könnte man jetzt hier mit Schrödingers Katze kommen und sagen, wenn ich jetzt mit einem anderen Blickwinkel beobachte, ändert das ja auch etwas.
Wenn du das kleine Kind, das sagt, der Kaiser ist ja nackt, tätigt er nur eine Beobachtung und tut sie kund. Aber das ist ja auch ein Sprachakt, der dann sofort das gesamte gesellschaftliche Situation ändert.
Dann frag ich mich natürlich, was ist jetzt drin in diesem Instrumentkasten? Ich meine, bisher habe ich erst mal nur gelernt von den Poststrukturalisten, dass irgendwie alles anders ist. Das ist ja schon mal ganz gut, und die Deutungshoheit liegt nicht bei mir. Was ist jetzt sozusagen das Instrument, was ich in diesem Zauberkasten entnehme, um meine Beobachtung zu ändern?
Naja, es ist ja nicht alles anders. Es ist nur, dass quasi die eine große emanzipatorische, aufklärerische Ideologie, nämlich der Marxismus, diese ganzen Minoritäten-Positionen, Schwul sein, Frau sein, Schwarz sein, quasi wenn überhaupt nur als Nebenwidersprüche in einem großen Geschichtsbild quasi mal so wegwischt und sagt, jetzt hab dich mal nicht so, im Kommunismus werden auch Schwule glücklich sein. Das ist das Beispiel dafür, weswegen das für denjenigen oder diejenige, die sich nicht repräsentiert fühlt, in einem bestimmten, vielleicht ja auch als gut anerkannten Bewegung, also typisch Hacker-Bewegung ist doch toll. Das ist ja auch ein emanzipatorischer Ansatz, also Aufklärung, was geschieht mit diesen Maschinen, sie aufzumachen, sie aufzubrechen. Gleichzeitig ist aber die Bewegung und die Sprache, in der diese Balls of Steel Award und Pipapo für Frauen als solche eine Sprache des anderen Geschlechts. Und dass überhaupt halt sich die Hexen da vor 10, 12 Jahren als so eine eigenständige Bewegung gegründet hat, liegt eben darin, dass sie die Erfahrung haben, ja, es gibt Praktiken, diese spezielle Perspektive einzubringen und eben darauf zu drängen, dass bitte, weil man ja eigentlich ein Teil dieser Bewegung ist und auch die Ziele und die Intentionen ja gut heißt und man möchte sich damit identifizieren und gleichzeitig wird man immer wieder an bestimmten Stellen darauf gestoßen, dass man doch nicht dazugehört. Und dieses Nicht-Dazugehören ist problematischer, weil es ja nicht darum geht, dass man das falsche Betriebssystem benutzt, sondern dass man das falsche Geschlecht hat, dass man über Balls of Steel gar nicht lachen kann, weil man selber ja diese Balls of Steel nie selber ausbilden kann, wenn man ein toller Hacker sein wollte. Und das ist eben ein Trauma, dieses Ausgeschlossensein. Und das ist gewissermaßen ein höheres Trauma, weil diese Ausschlussprinzipien eben auch nicht nur in der Hacker-Community stattfinden, sondern eben in der Gesamtgesellschaft, auch in den DAX-Konzernen passieren. Und dieselbe Sprache gesprochen wird, auf einer bestimmten Weise, so ein Boys Network Ding. Und dasselbe werden teilweise auch Schwule und dasselbe werden auch Leute mit Migrationshintergrund haben, die ja zum Teil von den Piraten, was heißt zum Teil, überwiegend von den Piraten und von dem CCC und von der Hacker-Community überhaupt nicht repräsentiert werden. Wo ist denn eigentlich ein junger Türke, der so in seiner Community sicherlich mit die volle digitale Nativeness hat? Wo kann der sich denn als Hacker irgendwo einbringen? Sieht der sich in der Anonymous-Maske repräsentiert von der Karikatur eines weißen katholischen Terroristen aus dem 17. Jahrhundert? Ja, also da geht es jetzt darum, die Legitimität einer solchen emanzipatorischen Bewegung wie Anonymous, die ist auch in dem Moment schon wieder diskreditiert, wenn es einfach nur um weiße Mittelschicht-Kits geht.
Ja, stellt sich natürlich die Frage, welche Maske kann man denn tragen, um wirklich alle abzubilden?
Na, erstmal geht es eben auch um die Frage, dass man mal klarmacht, diese Bewegung spricht eben nicht für alle, obwohl sie gleichzeitig den Anspruch hat, ein universales Freiheitsversprechen zu äußern und eine Diskursfreiheit in Fortscharn zu haben. Also gerade Fortscharn ist, vielleicht können wir da nochmal, das ist überhaupt Poststrukturalismus per se, als Programm.
Also Fortscharn, das Bild, das Imageboard, das hier ausführlich auch in CRE 121, zu den Internetmemen, auch nochmal ausführlich vorgestellt wurde, die meisten wahrscheinlich kennen, so ein bisschen auch als Quell aller Memen. Warum ist das?
Weil es die Memetik, also wenn man sie dann quasi da in dem Fortscharn sieht, und ich weiß nicht, ob Memetik inzwischen so eine kleine Spezialdisziplin ist, aber der Begriff wie Genetik, Memetik liegt ja nah. Und ein Meme ist das, was sich durch radikale Differentialität im Vergleich zu den anderen Zeichensystemen, und zwar Bilder sind natürlich Superzeichen, heraussticht. Und das heißt, die stärker die Differenz zu dem Erwarteten ist, also Rick Rowland zum Beispiel ist so ein typisches Ding, dir wird so eine Leimrute ausgelegt, du klickst drauf, und dann kommt dieser cheesy Rick Astley aus dieser, wie hieß denn der, dieses Produzenten Trio, Aitken Waterman, die hatten wie so Dieter Bohlen, so einen Hausklang. Ja, also das heißt, allein schon die Differenz zwischen Erwartung und Auflösung macht ein solches Aha-Erlebnis, dass du das auch irgendwie verarbeiten musst, diese Pointe, und die steckst du mal den anderen, weil da ist es nicht nur ein super Zeichen, sondern es ist gewissermaßen ja auch eine Art kommunikative Praxis, die gleich mit dahinter ist. Das ist eben auch Poststrukturalismus, also in dieser, sagen wir mal eher text-theoretischen Linie immer sehr, sehr schön, dass man quasi Zeichen, Text und Handlung quasi mit derselben, so als eine Gattung sehen kann, die wenn überhaupt nur sich als Unterkategorien unterscheiden, weil man sie ja alle dann wieder sprachlich referieren kann. Und ja, je herausragender dieses bestimmte Ereignis ist und sich von allen anderen vorhergehenden Peers und Erwartungen unterscheidet, desto höher ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es mimetische Qualität entwickelt. Und diese Differentialität, das gewissermaßen nicht das Ereignis, sondern nur der Abstand, das heißt die Differenz zwischen dem anderen Bildereignis in Forchon, quasi die ausschlaggebend ist für den mimetischen Charakter, das ist quasi die Grundlage der gesamten strukturalen Sprachwissenschaft, die nämlich sagt, es gibt Lautereignisse, die sind die Grundlage der Sprache. Und Lautereignisse können nur dann Sinträger werden, wenn sie als sogenannte Vornehme sind. Da sind wir wieder quasi Memen, Vornehmen und was war das bei Sehnen? Aber dieses Sehnen, ne war das von Dawkins.
Er spricht ja von Memen.
Aber er hat es doch von, wo hat er es denn abgegeben? Ah, von Gen. Genau. Aber eigentlich ist das Vornehmen das viel näher liegende Beispiel fürs Memen, weil das Vornehmen ist das kleinste bedeutungstragende Merkmal von Klangmustern. Und der Claude Lévi-Strauss, das war ein Ethnologe, der hat Roman Jacobson, einen Linguisten aus Russland in Amerika im Exil getroffen. Und der hat ihm quasi seine sprachstrukturalen Sprachmodelle gezeigt und ihm quasi vertraut gemacht mit dieser Idee des Vornehmens, der uns struktural im Sinne von, wir messen jetzt einfach mal im weitesten Sinne die Klangwelle. Und dann sehen wir, je größer das Klangbild von einzelnen Sprachereignissen voneinander unterscheidungsfähig ist, desto eher werden wir dort auch sehen, dass sich Sinnkommunikation anhand dieser starken Differenzen abbildet. Und der Claude Lévi-Strauss hat gesagt, ach toll, in meiner anthropologischen Tätigkeit habe ich den Verdacht, dass alle Menschen quasi einem bestimmten Urprogramm folgen und dass es gar keine qualitativen Unterschiede gibt zwischen dem sogenannten zivilisierten Menschen und dem wilden Menschen, sondern dass die alle einem bestimmten Urhandlungsmuster folgen und einfach quasi die entsprechenden Bausteine, aus denen diese Muster entstehen, einfach nur unterschiedlich sind und im Prinzip austauschbar werden. Also stell dir vor, du hast ein Muster, mal schön unkorrekten Hakenkreuz, das kannst du formal dadurch tätigen, dass sich zwei Balken in 90°-Winkel kreuzen und das quasi jeweils nochmal in 90° mit halber Länge der Urbalken quasi sich nochmal im Winkel von 90° dann nochmal dran gesetzt sind. Und jetzt kannst du dieses Hakenkreuz Formel mit Smarties, mit iPhones, auf dem Fußballring, mit Fans füllen. Du kannst einen Fackelmarsch mit Hakenkreuzträgern gestalten. Das Strukturmuster ist also immer dasselbe. Wenn man aber immer nur guckt, ah, Fackel, oh, iPhones, dann wirst du nie das dahinter liegende Muster erkennen, sondern du bleibst immer quasi, ah, es geht hier um Nahrungsmittel, das sind ja Smarties, esse ich schnell auf, Hakenkreuz weg. Und so kommt man natürlich dazu, oh, das ist eine hochzivilisierte Technologie, die haben auf ihrem Tisch lauter iPhones liegen. Aber solange du dich auf die iPhones konzentrierst, und nicht siehst, das sind Nazis, Nazis, die es einmal mit iPhones kommunizieren, das andere mal mit Smarties, kommst du nicht an die Wahrheit dran. Und das hat er quasi als Grundidee gehabt, der Claude Lévi-Strauss, und hat quasi den Strukturalismus in die Anthropologie gebracht. Und hat dann gesagt, okay, Gesellschaften haben so bestimmte Uhr, Erzähl- und Handlungsmuster, die dann auch wiederum mit der Psychoanalyse zusammenhängen, also Inzest-Tabu, wie heiraten, Engverwandte, Stämme miteinander, wie wird also Sofortpflanzung und so was organisiert. Und da ist ihm, also da hat er sich quasi von all diesen Gesellschaften, die Mythen und Erzählungen erzählen lassen. Teilweise hat er sie gelesen, weil sie in der schriftlichen Kultur vorliegen, also zum Beispiel im Ödipus-Legende der Griechen. Und hat dann quasi eine strukturale Analyse gemacht und so etwas wie ein vollkommen abstrahiertes Programm entwickelt, wo er gesagt hat, der Ödipus-Mythos ist nur ein bestimmter Ausdruck eines allgemeinen, menschlichen Handlungsmusters zur Vermeidung von Inzest und den damit verbundenen, auch erbschädigenden Elementen. Und wenn man dann so eine strukturale Analyse auf dieser Ebene der Mytheme, weil er hat dann quasi die Idee des Vornehmens quasi eben so narrative Einzelelemente quasi gefasst, die sich insbesondere wiederum durch so eine maximale Distanz, also wiederum so ein Differenzereignis.
Im Prinzip ist das die Digitalisierung, die Abzählbarkeit, die klare Trennung von abstrakten Einheiten.
Aber es gibt keinen Sinn mehr in den Einheiten, sondern nur in den Relationen. Da versteckt sich der Sinn. Und der kann quasi durch austauschbare, auf der Wahrnehmungsebene, durch Erzähl, also schon Sinsesysteme.
Die Semantik ist das sozusagen.
Ja, aber ein Mythem ist zum Beispiel, dass der Ödipus seinen Vater tötet. Warum ist das ein Mythem? Das ist ein Mythem, weil es ein sehr starkes Element ist. Ein Sohn tötet seinen Vater. Ein weiteres Element ist, der Sohn schläft mit der Mutter. Und ein weiteres ist, er weiß davon aber gar nichts. Er weiß weder, dass er den Vater tötet, noch, dass er mit der Mutter schläft. Das sind immer so maximale Unwahrscheinlichkeiten, die dann als dramatische Elemente, Mytheme darstellen. Und da sind wir quasi wieder so an dieser Nähe auch wieder zum Memen. Also quasi das maximal Unwahrscheinliche ist in unserer Filtertätigkeit des menschlichen Sensoriums besonders herausragend und wird gewissermaßen dann bevorzugt verarbeitet. Und nur jetzt hier weiter kommt diese strukturelle Analyse, die der Claude-Lévi-Strauss jetzt zur Darstellung von quasi so Archetypen von Erzählmustern entwickelt hat. Die hat die Literaturwissenschaft aufgenommen und hat sie quasi benutzt, um damit schon vorhandene Romane und alles nochmal neu zu lesen, weil sie gesagt haben, boah, so ein Mythos wie Oedipus ist doch eigentlich Literatur, ist doch das, was es auch bei Madame Bovary gibt. Jetzt müssen wir quasi einfach einen Roman, den wir bisher quasi so auf dieser Oberflächenebene gelesen haben, quasi auch in Mytheme oder in Narratheme quasi zerlegen und kommen damit quasi auf eine tiefen Struktur von Textanalyse, auf die wir bisher nicht gestoßen sind.
Erzähl-Atome.
Ja. Und dann kommt gewissermaßen der Poststruktur...
Hat das funktioniert? Würde ja im Umkehrschluss, wenn dem so sei, dass kulturübergreifend, sprachübergreifend, zeitübergreifend alle Menschen letztlich mehr oder weniger nachweisbar, sich aus dem selben Vorgangs, Erzähl- und Sprachatomalphabet bedienen und dass alles rekombinierbar wäre. Wer das findet, der hätte ja sozusagen die ultimative Übersetzungsmaschine gefunden und könnte über Zeiten und Kulturen und Sprachen hinweg alles in alles transformieren.
Und jetzt denk mal drüber nach, warum ein Mann wie Noam Chomsky so ein gefragter, allgemein universalspezial Experte ist, weil er in seinem Hauptberuf nämlich einem Konstrukt, einer Theorie, einer Universal-Grammatik folgt. Noam Chomsky ist allerdings ein Gegner des Poststrukturalismus, das war ihm alles zu essayistisch. Vor allen Dingen, weil der Poststrukturalismus wiederum sagt, naja, diese Differenzen, die quasi dann mal festgestellt werden und die jetzt im Sinne meines Beispiels mit dem Konzept Hakenkreuz, das steht dann irgendwann mal fest. Wenn du mal die Smarties und die Handys und einfach diese Struktur Hakenkreuz mal festgelegt hast, dann ist das immer gleich. Und der Poststrukturalismus geht halt einen Schritt weiter und sagt, diese Differenzen, die darf man nicht als festgelegte Entitäten sehen. Also im Sinne von, weil das einmal so einen großen Sprung hatte.
Die Differenzen zwischen den einzelnen...
Ja, das ist ja ein Wert. Zwischen einzelnen Ereignissen. Auch jetzt, wenn du also jetzt bei Forchan irgendwie 500 blaue Bilder hast und hast du auf einmal ein rotes Bild, dann wird das wahrscheinlich als Mem eher in Frage kommen, als wenn jetzt das 500 und erste blaue Bild kommt. Das heißt, dann kannst du ja die Differenz zwischen blau und rot in einer Zahl ausdrücken. Und das liegt ja gewissermaßen in der mathematischen Praxis, dass du irgendwann mal anfängst, Differenzen wie, nicht mehr als Relation quasi nicht mehr abgeleitet von den Positionen, aus denen heraus sie bestimmt ist, sondern gewissermaßen als Wert, als Entität für sich zu nehmen und gar nicht mehr zu sehen, wovon es ist eigentlich abgeleitet. Und das mag der Poststrukturalismus nicht. Der sagt, es gibt keine festen Werte, auch in den Differenzen nicht, sondern die ändern sich, das sind Zuschreibungen, die können sich immer wieder verändern. Und zum Beispiel innerhalb eines Sprachsystems, wo wir jetzt ja miteinander sprechen, hat ja jedes Wort irgendwo seinen Sinn durch das phonetische Ereignis. Metaebene zum Beispiel. Ich kann jetzt, wenn ich das Wort Metaebene, das Studio, dein gesamtes Kompendium an verschiedenen Podcasts, da gibt es also verschiedene Semantiken, die sich hinter Metaebene verstecken. Es gibt auch noch den allgemeinen Begriff Metaebene. Aber in dem Kontext, in dem wir uns jetzt bewegen, sage ich, ich bin in der Metaebene, dann ist das Studio gemeint. Das ist eine relativ klare Zuschreibung, aber man sieht schon, es gibt Differenzen eigentlich auch schon. Es gibt keine absolute Zuschreibung für Metaebene, weil im jeweiligen Kontext ändert sich das vollkommen klar. Das ist quasi das, was so ein analytischer Sprachphilosoph sehen würde. Aber wenn dann mal so eine Zuschreibung wie Metaebene als Ort da ist, als klangliches Ereignis, aber auch in Differenz zu Metaebene als theoretischer Begriff und Metaebene als Compendium von existierenden Podcasts, dann ist das mal festgelegt. Also, und dann befinden wir uns quasi in einer festgelegten, strukturalen Tableau, wo du drei Werte hast. Metaebene als theoretisches Konstrukt ist ungleich Metaebene Studio von Tim, ist ungleich seinem Podcast-Sammelalbum. Und Metaebene ist gewissermaßen phonetisch, unterschieden von anderen, von Maitebene, von Clubmate, ist es nicht die Mate-Ebene. Also da haben wir denn quasi eine andere phonetische Differenzierung. Und das ist soweit klar. Jetzt kommt aber noch die Idee dahinter, die der, also in dieser radikalen poststrukturalistischen Sicht von Derrida vor allen Dingen, der sagt Nee, auch auf der zeitlichen, auf der rekursiven Ebene ist Metaebene nie mit sich identisch. Also wenn ich sage, ich bin in der Metaebene, dann ist der Satz, ich bin in der Metaebene und die Wiederholung, ich bin in der Metaebene, nicht immer derselbe Satz, sondern spätestens beim dritten Mal von ich bin in der Metaebene war es klar, dass ich gar nicht mehr über den Satz ich bin in der Metaebene als eine Ortsbeschreibung, sondern dass ich gewissermaßen das dritte Glied einer Reihe von Wiederholungen als Beispiel gebracht habe. Und diese, in spätestens dieser dritten Wiederholung, war das also ein Beispiel für die Reihung von, also eine Rekursivwiederholung und hatte also die Uraussage, ich bin in der Metaebene, war nicht mehr da. Könnte ich mal jetzt sagen, okay, ist eine Kontextänderung. Vorher hat der Gregor gesagt, ich bin in der Metaebene, jetzt macht er ein Beispiel über eine Reihung und nimmt dasselbe Ding und sagt es dreimal, Kontextverschiebung, wo ist das Problem?
Kann aber auch sein, dass du jetzt wirklich gemeint hast, du befindest dich inhaltlich auf einer Metaebene.
Zum Beispiel. Aber es ist noch viel radikaler. Jetzt versuche ich nämlich mal zu zeigen, dass man experimentell diese Radikalität des Zeichenbegriffs, des Poststrukturalismus wirklich nachweisen kann, indem ich quasi ein Klangereignis, das semantisch und eben auch in der Syntagmatik gewissermaßen eine klare Verortung hat. Ich bin in der Metaebene, Ort Metaebene, Studio, dass man dieses Wortzeichen gewissermaßen aus dem Gesamtsystem Sprache herauslösen kann und zu einem reinen Klangereignis machen kann. Und da sind wir jetzt fast wieder so im Zen-Buddhismus, indem man daraus so ein Mantra macht und ich jetzt mehrfach Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, Metaebene, das ist die radikale Differentialität. Das Klangereignis ist irgendwann nicht mehr unterscheidbar. Es fällt gewissermaßen durch diese, durch diese vielen Wiederholungen, verliert es quasi seinen festen Platz in der Ordnung der Sprache. Und was wir hier jetzt, ist ein höchst unwahrscheinliches Beispiel, aber jeder hat das mal gemacht, dass er so Tourette-mäßig oder sonst wo vor sich hin so ein Wort, ein Satz vor sich hin brabbelt, bis irgendwann dieser Satz nur noch als reines phonetisches Klangereignis sich von der semantischen Ebene gelöst hat und einfach nur so frei flottiert. Und, ja und damit ist aber auch, also wenn du Zeichen so herauswaschen kannst, aus der Struktur, wer kann dir dann sagen, dass die Zeichen Wahrheit vermitteln? Das kann ja gar nicht sein, das ist ja nur eine Konvention, also und die Differentialität ist eben nicht nur eine statische, sondern eigentlich, und das ist in der Radikalität, ich glaube, wir sprengen dann auch den Rahmen, den wir hier haben. Der Derrida geht also quasi in seinen Zeichenbegriffen, da sind wir jetzt wieder wirklich so am Higgs-Syndrom dran, mit so einem imaginären Zernbeschleuniger, den wir jetzt quasi eingesetzt haben, mit dem Mantra.
Wir beschleunigen einfach die Metaebene so sehr, bis sie sich nur noch in Licht und Energie teilt.
Ja, sie hat sich quasi dann auch ständig wieder selbst eingeholt. Der Derrida einfach sagt, es geht nicht nur um das Unterschiedensein, sondern es geht auch um das Aufschieben und Aufgeschoben werden. Der Sinn eines Wortes oder eines Zeichens, aber ich nehme jetzt einfach mal ein Wort, ist gewissermaßen immer schon eine Abgeschlossenheit. Ich bin in der Metaebene, versteht man in dem Moment erst im Nachhinein durch die Kontextualisierung, durch die verschiedenen, durch die Syntagmatik der verschiedenen Lautelemente, die man zu einem Satz zusammenbaut. Und erst wenn dieser Prozess abgeschlossen ist, hast du ein Verständnis davon, was jetzt eigentlich an Sinn produziert wird. Das ist also eine Relativität von Sinnproduktion. Das heißt, diesen Begriff Metaebene, den kann man auch nicht einfach so reinschmeißen, weil er, selbst wenn man, er hat keine absolute Präsenz, sondern erst in der in der Aktion des Sprachgebrauchs wird sein wirklicher Gehalt erkennbar. Es ist also nicht nur die reine Unterscheidung zu einem anderen ähnlichen Klangereignis, sondern gewissermaßen erst die eine einzige singuläre Gebrauch in einer speziellen, klar definierten, vollkommen originären Sprachsituation und Kontextsituation erzeugt den Sinn. Aber immer erst nach dem und nicht, wenn man schon quasi, das ist nicht wie so die Lettern aus dem gutenbergischen Setzkasten, dass du den einfach zu dem Buchstaben M nimmst und dahintust und jeder weiß, das ist immer ein M, sondern quasi erst in dem Moment, wo du dieses Ding da eingesetzt hast und es gedruckt hast, dann entsteht gewissermaßen erst diese wirkliche Sinnproduktion a posteriori. Das heißt nach dem Ereignis und nicht schon a priori als eine Wahrheit, wie im Setzkasten. Dieser Setzkasten, das ist quasi die Struktur. Und der Poststrukturalismus sagt, nee, nee, diesen festen Setzkasten, den gibt es nicht. Das ist mehr wie so ein Scrabble, wie so eine Buchstaben Nudelsuppe, wo man sich was rausfischt. Aber man hätte ja auch, du suchst einen M und holst dir ein M, aber es hätte auch ein anderes sein können.
Ja, also ich, das steckt halt viel drin, so im Sinne von, es kann alles sein. Also seid euch eurer Sprache und Wertaussagen nicht sicher, wir finden immer wieder einen Weg. Wie man sagen kann, es bedeutet eigentlich was ganz anderes. Auf der anderen Seite gibt das natürlich auch noch eine unglaubliche Unsicherheit. Denn wenn dem so ist, dass ich da alles auflöse und das gar nichts mehr irgendeine Bedeutung hat, was, dann können wir ja auch an dem Moment einfach verstummen, jegliche Kommunikation einstellen, da wir ja nicht mehr in der Lage sind, ihr irgendeine Bedeutung zuschreiben zu können und das ist ja nun mal der Sinn der ganzen Geschichte. Die Sprache hat sich ja entwickelt, genau, um eben eine Verständigung, so eine Digitalisierung und Abzählbarkeit der Dinge und damit eben auch eine Bedeutungszuordnungsmöglichkeit überhaupt zu entwickeln. Darum widerspricht ja dann eigentlich auch diese Aussage des Poststrukturalismus. Ja, jetzt haben wir hier irgendwie Struktur geschaffen über Jahrtausende, die sich auch laufend ändert. Hört man sich jemand an, der vor 200 Jahren gesprochen hat, gibt es leider keine passenden Tondokumente, aber bei Schrift fällt einem das ja schon deutlich auf. Da hat man dann schon Schwierigkeiten zu verstehen. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich, wenn ich mich jetzt 500 Jahre zurückbeame, mich mit den Deutschen oder den Deutsch-Sprechenden oder diese Sprache, aus der dann irgendwann Deutsch wird, sprechen, ob ich überhaupt eine Chance hätte, mich mit denen zu verständigen, weil selbst wenn ich auf ähnliche Worte treffe, bedeuten sie vielleicht nicht dasselbe, aber in dem Kontext der Zeit ist das ja sehr wohl der Fall.
Viel wichtiger wäre einfach, dass du da aufgepoppt wärst und niemand wüsste, aus welchem gesellschaftlichen Nabatiff du eigentlich entsprungen bist.
Dann fang ich an zu reden und bin zwei Stunden später tot.
Interessant wäre gewesen, dass man dich vielleicht für wahnsinnig erklärt hätte.
Das wäre wahrscheinlich meine einzige Hoffnung.
Foucault hat halt wunderbar auch, hat halt die Geschichte des Wahnsinns gewissermaßen erklärt. Er hat einfach gesagt, früher war der Wahnsinnige einfach Teil der Gesellschaft.
Ich hab so ein paar Freunde, die sind auch wahnsinnig und die fallen auch durch ihre Sprache auf. Die fallen auch dadurch auf, dass niemand sie versteht.
Ja, wir haben ja gewissermaßen... Gut, aber wir bewegen uns ja schon nicht umsonst. Hast du ja einen deiner vielen Podcasts-Kanäle, heißt der The Lunatic Finge. Das heißt, in deiner Praxis hast du ja schon sehr viel von diesem poststrukturalistischen Konzept angesetzt, dass du eben den Mainstream vom Rande her, von dem Nebenstrudel, wo sich irgendwo etwas so sammelt, das nicht in diesem großen Fluss weiter nach unten gespült wird. Dass es da ganz interessant ist, quasi in diesen Seiten- Aspekten Erkenntnisse über das Gesamtsystem zu erzielen, dass man von der Mitte des Flusses aus nicht erkennen kann. Das ist also auch eine ganz wichtige Erkenntnis von Diskurspraxis, dass du, auch wenn der Poststrukturalismus sagt, es gibt keinen Außen, so heißt es nicht, dass es nicht doch Ränder gäbe.
Ja, ich meine, das ist sehr wichtig, weil in dem Moment, wo man natürlich eingetaucht ist in die Sprachgewalt und die normative Kraft des Faktischen, ist man natürlich auch nicht mehr in der Lage, irgendwelche Dinge noch zu erkennen oder zumindest wird es einem sehr schwer gemacht.
Doch, aber das wäre die Programmatik und das ist eigentlich auch das, was diese vielfältigen Diskurssysteme, die aufeinander prallen, also gerade jetzt hier so in unserer Twitter-Netz- Community-Welt, wirst du ständig herausgefordert, auch deine eigene Sprache und Sprachgebrauch immer ständig zu reflektieren und auch zu überlegen, wie es im Gesamtsystem aufgefasst wird. Das stimmt. Und das finde ich, ist gewissermaßen so, da muss man eben dieses theoretische Konstrukt gar nicht aufgenommen haben, sondern aus der Praxis, dass wenn man sich da falsch verhält, wird man zum Troll. Wenn du Troll bist, kannst du noch mehr trollen, aber irgendwann wirst du abgeschaltet. Und dann bist du eben nicht mehr da, wo du eigentlich sein möchtest, weil man möchte...
Weil sich der heilige Shitstorm irgendwie vom Felsen gespült hat.
Ja, denn du willst ja schon, dass du mit deiner Stimme wahrnehmbar bist und willst eben nicht draußen stehen und...
Das erfordert sozusagen eine poststrukturalistische Herangehensweise. Das ist das, was du sagen willst.
Ich will vor allen Dingen sagen, dass es durchaus... Also, du hattest vorhin gesagt, man könnte im eigenen sprechen gewissermaßen die Grundlagen dieser eigenen Sprache nicht richtig... Man wäre blind dagegen über. Nein, die Lehre, die man draus ziehen muss, ist quasi immer zum Rand der eigenen Annahmen zu gehen und immer quasi auch wechselnde Standpunkte zu sich selber einzunehmen, zu versuchen, quasi die Standpunkte anderer Personen im Diskurs einzunehmen. Und das ist natürlich immer ein Bias drin. Aber mit diesen quasi so eine Fassigesprächspositionierung, wo man ständig auch mal wechselnd andere Stimmen einnimmt, also gerade bei Twitter ist es ja ganz interessant, man setzt, macht OH und macht Anführungsstriche, da kannst du ganz anders sprechen, als wenn du selber sprichst. Also das ist also so eine Repositionierung der eigenen Sprachposition, weil du ja doch ein Begehren hast, das mitzuteilen, weil das eine mimetische Qualität hat, weil es besonders originell ist, weil du es anprangern willst oder weil du etwas sagen willst, wo du weißt, wenn du es so sagen würdest, würdest du geblockt werden, also erfindest du quasi den OH und machst den Zitat.
OH für die Leute, die ihn auf Kürze nicht kennen, overheard, quasi die Zitatregel für Twitter oder überhaupt für das Netz.
Genau, eben auch für das Netz und auch wenn du überlegst, wie wichtig diese Identitätsspielereien für die Netzkultur waren und jetzt diese Klarnamen-Geschichte, also da geht es immer um Konflikte, die auf Grundlage dieser poststrukturalistischen und vor allen Dingen von Foucault beeinflussten Diskursanalyse alle schon angesprochen worden sind, dass wenn du klar identifiziert bist, hast du schon so eine soziale Position im Diskurs, du kannst nicht mal was in eine andere Position einnehmen, dieses in der Internet Nobody-knows-your-dog-Ding, diese klaren gesellschaftlichen Zuschreibungen, die Menschen wollen quasi diese Fuzziness haben. Und das ist eigentlich, weil sie auch eine Qualität darstellen, weil es eine Qualität ist und das ist für mich, ganz egal ob mich jetzt da jemand für verdammt, das ist für mich Poststrukturalismus, dass man aus diesem klaren Kästchendenken einer Struktur herausbrechen kann und Post im Sinne von, ja auch immer, es ist nicht so festgelegt, es kann immer auch anders sein. Und das ist doch ein Gewinn und ich sehe auch eine Praxis darin und ich habe das Gefühl, das sind die theoretischen Grundlagen, die diese wirklich ja getätigten Kommunikationsformen quasi unterfüttert und ihnen auch dadurch eine gewisse Relevanz geben. Dasselbe auch nochmal, um ein paar populärkulturelle Geschichten abzudecken. Techno, der Tod des Autors. Also es war nicht mehr der Musiker Gott, der als Komponist entsprechend sich hingestellt hat, sich auf der Bühne hat abfeiern lassen, sondern es ist der, abfeiern darf sich überhaupt nur noch der Mixer, der quasi aus ganz vielen Elementen, aus ganz verschiedenen Diskurse zusammenmischt, das neu zusammenbringt und dadurch eine gewisse Respektabilität und Wahrnehmbarkeit hat. Aber der so... Der DJ, je mehr er sich gewissermaßen zur Eigenposition macht, desto lächerlicher macht er sich, weil wenn nämlich keiner zu seiner Musik tanzt, dann ist DJ Gott steht ganz alleine da und hat gar nichts. Das heißt, er ist auch immer auf diesen Resonanzraum angewiesen. Also überhaupt, dass es eine Musik war, die keinerlei Aussagen mehr auf der Textebene gebracht hat, sondern zu dieser reinen, langanhaltenden Strom mit anderen Menschen dran war. Auch das ist wieder so ein Aufbrechen von diesen taxonomischen Gittern. Also Poststrukturismus gesehen als eine Veränderung des Aggregatzustands. Auf einmal bist du Teil einer Masse und du wirst mit so einem Rhythmus injiziert, der dich in die eine oder andere Richtung greift. Und diese Teilentmächtigung, dass man sich als Individuum in so einer Masse einrändern kann, ist ein großartiger Ausstieg und Alternativprogramm gewesen zu dieser sonstigen, funktionalen und gestreamlineden Individualität, wo man halt zu funktionieren hat als Einzelperson. Und diese Analogie wurde auch teilweise von Techno-DJs und Labels auch direkt aufgegriffen. Also es gab eben ein Frankfurter Label, das nannte sich Mille Plateau, das explizit auf die Lösung Guattari zurechtgegangen ist. Und diese Auflösungstendenzen sind eben quasi dann in dieser psychoanalytischen Sicht, diese Rückkehr in diesen Urmutterzustand, wo man einfach so aufgelöst vor sich hin blubbert, in der Mutterbauch. Und für mich auf den Punkt bringt halt dieses ganze, eben der Film Matrix, der für mich quasi der Film zur Theorie ist.
Zu welcher Theorie?
Zur poststrukturalistischen Theorie. Weil wir ja mit dem Neo, der schon eine Differenz, also eine Dissidenz zum System hat und er denkt, er hätte eine, weil er ist der Hacker. Und das ist also der Einstieg, das ist, wissen wir mal, was denn da, wo der Film das Publikum abholt. Man kann sich mit der Figur des Neo identifizieren. Und das Werbe-Toll ist, dass ihm quasi jetzt Zugang zu dem geheimen Schatz, willst du wissen, was die Matrix ist. Aber das wirkt natürlich erst mal innerweltlich. Es kommt dann diese erste erschreckendes Element, dass er seine Sprache verliert, weil er seinen Mund verliert. Wo du einfach nach etwa 20 Minuten merkst, ich bin hier nicht in so einem typischen Hacker-Krimi.
Sondern dieser Film geht jetzt auf eine ganz andere Ebene.
Das ist eine Genre-Klappe. Und hochinteressant dann der blaue oder rote Pille-Situation, wo der Morpheus ihn halt, also der Gott des Schlafes, wichtig natürlich für die Psychoanalyse, weil dieser Gott muss ja erst mal seine Macht ausbreiten, damit man träumen kann und in diesen Träumen gewissermaßen einen anderen Zugang zum Unterbewussten erfährt. Und an dieser Stelle wird quasi diese klassische Zuschreibung von dem Rabbit Hole und der Alice-Geschichte eigentlich abgebrochen. Und es beginnt was noch viel perfideres, nämlich das Spiel mit dem Spiegel. Er hat, glaube ich, ist es die, weiss nicht, welche Pille ist eigentlich, die Matrix-Pille, die rote oder die blaue? Okay, er hat sich dann ja für die rote entschieden. Und dann gibt es eine Szene, die ist quasi eine Urszene aus dem Konzept von diesem Psychoanalytiker Lacan. Der mit zu diesen Poststrukturalisten gezählt wird, obwohl er eigentlich psychoanalytisch gearbeitet hat und als Psychoanalytiker auch überhaupt nicht anerkannt war. Also das war ein totaler Freak und hat sich 7000 Mal in neuen psychoanalytischen Gesellschaften neu organisieren müssen, weil sie ihn überall rausgeschmissen haben. Neo hat also diese rote Pille geschluckt und dann guckt er in den Spiegel. Und auf einmal sieht er sich nicht nur im Spiegel, sondern dieser Spiegel bewegt sich ja und er saugt ihn ein. Und es gibt quasi diese...
Also mit dem Finger...
Ja, und es gibt so eine Urszene, die dieser Lakan schon aus der Beobachtung, aus der Empirie von realen Kindern entwickelt hat, dass wenn das Kind sich das erste Mal als Einheit im Spiegel erkennt und gleichzeitig ein großes Erschrecken, er hat benutzt sogar das deutsche Wort AHA-Erlebnis erlebt, weil quasi all die Teilelemente von Körperhaftigkeit und Körperwahrnehmung auf einmal zu so einem Gesamtbild visuell zusammengefasst werden. Aber es ist natürlich auch eine große Desillusionierung. Einerseits ist das AHA-Erlebnis, das bin ich, und gleichzeitig habe ich mich mir vielleicht ganz anders vorgestellt. Und daraus entsteht auch so eine Abkapselung des Selbst zum Sich, dass es halt dann doch was anderes ist. Und das ist also quasi eine psychoanalytische Urszene, die also bei Matrix, also das AHA-Erlebnis, wird fast eins zu eins dann benutzt, um Neo in die eigentliche Erkenntnisphäre zu bringen. Und insofern ist zumindest von der Anlage her Matrix natürlich dann grandios, weil wir dann in diesem Film lernen, dass die Realität ja nur ein Code ist. Und so wie der Poststrukturismus ja darauf guckt, zwischen all den Oberflächlichkeiten, den Texturen, die auf den Code gemapt sind, irgendwann dahinter zu blicken. Das heißt, überall den wahren Text, den wahren Code zu erkennen. Das ist ja das Programm der Cultural Studies, die Texttheorie auf alles ansetzen. Und Nioh ist eben auch die Figur, die im Laufe seiner Entwicklungsgeschichte genau diese Fähigkeit entwickelt, hinter die Texturen des Systems zu schauen und zu erkennen, das ist alles nur Text, das ist alles nur Setzung, das ist alles nur Erfindung. Und sich dann quasi auch dagegen zu verhalten, indem er sagt, wenn das dann alles nur Setzung ist, dann setze ich jetzt mit meinem Willen etwas dagegen, was dann systemaufsprengend ist. Und das ist wieder, finde ich, die positive, hyperaufklärerische Sichtweise auf Poststrukturalismus. Das heißt, hinter den die Texturen zu gucken, auf den eigentlichen Code und zu wissen, wenn das alles nicht wahr ist, bin ich zurückgeworfen auf mich selbst und auf meinen Willen, auf mein Sein und kann dann etwas dagegen setzen. Das ist vielleicht die amerikanische Philosophie, die dann doch dahinter ist. Weil bei aller, wenn ich nur sage, das sind Analogien zur Theorie, dann ist natürlich auf der wirklichen, semantischen Ebene natürlich Matrix trotzdem vollkommen konventionell, weil ja doch nur ein, es ist eine Heldengeschichte, er sieht die falschen Verhältnisse, sie werden aufgedeckt. Das Individuum selber ist davon gar nicht angekratzt, sondern jetzt quasi mit dem richtigen Bewusstsein entwickelt er die richtigen Schritte und bekämpft die Feinde. Und das ist dann wieder konventionell. Interessant ist dann natürlich nochmal diese Situation, wie er dann aufwacht und quasi ein, zumindest in der Verfilmung, unverstelltes Bild auf die menschliche Existenz, als so ein Petrischalen-Ding hat, was ja gewissermaßen dann auch wieder diese technische Substitution für die Gebärmutter ist.
Was meinst du jetzt, wo er aufwacht? Achso, wo er in seinem Kokon erwacht.
Und er sitzt doch in so einer weißen Petrischale und guckt und sieht, dass er in so einem riesigen biegen Waben stammt von Millionen von anderen, die auch alle in so einer Petrischale liegen und sich quasi von ihren eigenen Fäkalien irgendwie so wie Lachsfarmen gefüttert werden. Das ist insofern ein schönes, sehr kritisches Bild, weil es quasi die maximal depressive Sicht auf das Individuum im Kapitalismus darlegt. Also all das, was du bist, ist nur, dass du ein Stoffwechsel-Erzeuger innerhalb des kapitalistischen Superorganismus bist. Und all deine Existenz, von der du denkst, du wärst frei, wird dir nur in einer Scheinwelt vorgespielt, die, wenn du es denn wirklich erkennen würdest, eigentlich zum spontanen Abort führen muss. Und dann wird halt die Matrix-Verfilmung halt sehr cheesy, weil es dann ja quasi eine reale Welt zu geben scheint, die nicht mehr hinterfragt wird. Was eigentlich schade ist, weil in der zweiten Fassung, und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es da vielleicht auch die eine und andere Drehbuch-Fassung gibt, die da in eine andere Richtung geschlagen ist, denn es entwickelt dann ja der Neo in der sogenannten realen Welt dann wieder dieselben Neo-Checker und Banding-Fähigkeiten, die er vorher quasi so als Super-User oder Super-Avatar in der Scheinwelt hat. So dass ja eigentlich logisch gewesen wäre, auch diese Matrix-Zion-Vorspiegelung, dass die eigentlich auch nur ein weiterer Level ist und das wäre eigentlich auch die konsequentere und interessantere Lösung gewesen, um das Ding weiterzuspielen. Für mich ist eigentlich die...
Dann hätte es auch noch einen 4.0.5.
Teil geben können. Für mich ist die eigentliche reale Welt in Matrix das Ladeprogramm, diese totale weiße Ebene und finde ich großartig, wo dann vor allen Dingen dieses reine Wunschdenken dazu führt, dass alles passiert.
Du willst Waffen haben, Kilometer capen von Regalen ziehen an dir vorbei.
Und das ist quasi so, dieses Ladeprogramm zeigt gewissermaßen die Unendlichkeit in der Möglichkeit des Begehrens, den Mensch haben kann, weil er sich halt alles vorstellen kann. Und es ist natürlich total cheesy, wenn es dann auch noch alles passiert. Aber gleichzeitig auch in der in der Schnelligkeit entspricht es natürlich auch ein bisschen, wie das Internet uns jetzt hinsichtlich der kulturellen Leistung so ein bisschen überversorgt, weil ja alles immer da ist, wie im Ladeprogramm.
So immer noch nicht so schnell, wie man es haben will, aber schon viel zu schnell, um es wirklich noch kommunizieren zu können.
An dem Punkt wäre ich jetzt, wo ich bei dem ersten Folge 91 eigentlich einsteigen wollte, weil ich habe, glaube ich, dir da so einen Matrix, einen kleinen Besinnungsabstrakt verfasst, um gewissermaßen zu zeigen, wie poststrukturalistische Theoreme, noch mehr Eme, Theoreme sind eben die kleinsten theoret-haltigen Sätze.
Ich frage mich gerade, was die Podcastoeme sind, was hier die kleinste Einheit an Podcasts ist, die wir hier abwerfen können.
Ein Podem oder ein Custom? Ich würde sagen, wer jetzt ein gewisses Interesse und eine Neugier dafür hat, sollte versuchen, entweder in die Originaltexte einzusteigen oder ich werde es auch noch mal in die Links geben. Es gibt eine wunderbare Vorlesung, die als Text bei Zuckamp 1993 erschienen ist von Manfred Frank, einem quasi Gegner des Poststrukturalismus, der aber wie alle Gegner natürlich mit besonderer Energie sich seines Gegenstands angenommen hat und dass er dann fast bis zur Unkenntlichkeit mit ihm verschmilzt. Also man kann gewissermaßen Poststrukturalismus auch aus einer guten Position herauslesen und es ist faszinierend.
Die größten Kritiker der Elche wurden schließlich selber welche.
Und er bietet auch so was wie einen historischen Kompromiss zwischen der eher deutschen Schule der Hermeneutik und der französischen poststrukturalistischen Sicht an, die dann wirklich so verschmilzt wie hinterher bei Monty Python, die beiden Fraktionen der palästinensischen Befreiungs...
Die Volksfront.
Genau, also da passt dann eigentlich kein Blatt mehr dazwischen. Das sind eher so Vektoren, aus denen das Denken quasi auf eine selbe Figur hingeht. Und das kann ich sehr empfehlen und mehr, also wer das verstanden hat, der hat das Top-Checkertum erreicht.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch eine schöne Vision für diese Shitstorm-Realität, dass die ganzen Leute sich so dermaßen irgendwie auf Themen so gegenseitig einschießen, dass sie dann auch irgendwann zu einer gewissen Kongruenz kommen.
Zwangsläufig.
Das ist mal eine Sendung gewesen, wo ich mir vorher nicht auch nur ein einziges Wort als Notiz gemacht habe mit der Ausnahme einiger Merkhilfen bezüglich des Inhalts der alten Sendung. Normalerweise stelle ich daran ja immer fest, ob ich jetzt zu einem Ende gekommen bin, aber ich glaube, wir sind zu dem Ende gekommen, oder?
Ist gut.
Wir haben mehr als zwei Stunden gebraucht, das war sozusagen noch zu beweisen, dass man, wenn man mehr als zwei Stunden hat, auch mehr sagen kann. Beziehungsweise, ähm, tja, man kann schon fast fünf Stunden schwatzen hier über diesen ganzen Kontext. Ich fand hier auf jeden Fall einen tollen Einblick, hat mir eine ganze Menge neuer Aspekte gegeben. Und ich hoffe, so war es auch bei euch, ihr Hörer, der Metaebene. Und zwar der Metaebene auf allen möglichen Bedeutungsebenen, die dieses Wort haben kann. Ja, und dann leite ich jetzt das Ende ein, ganz geschickt. Das war's. Chaosradio heißt es ja nicht mehr, sondern CRE. Trotzdem war es die Fortsetzung der alten Sendung. Und gucken, schauen wir uns noch zum dritten Teil? Keine Ahnung. Das lassen wir jetzt mal offen, da könnt ihr euch die eigene Bedeutung machen. Also sagen wir nur noch Tschüss.